today takes a second for all the streams
to go
up let's start with uh this crazy carb
sweep and then we'll start coding on the
mooba so I ran this
overnight it's still actually running
and I'm going to let it keep running
while I uh I Dev on this a little bit
because this did ridiculously well
it's funny that there's still some
trials that uh don't perform very well I
think it's a little
noisy but this is just crushed previous
baselines on this environment so this is
awesome to
see posted this as well um the main
thing is that the graphs actually work
and we have some super high performance
environments to test stuff on let me
real quick tweet the stream out from
this and we'll just go straight into um
we'll go straight into uh coding on this
stuff so let's just
do
okay that sounds
good
perfect so let's go to uh write to
code where we left this off
yesterday we got right we got like the
basic Tower AI the really really basic
Jank Tower AI to work we got agents that
can run around they can kind of fight
each other a little bit
um oh this is fine this is just the I I
had a gift saving thing so yeah it it's
uh it works all fine so there's a lot of
stuff we can do today I
think I want to push the logic on this
until it gets kind of
complicated right a little too
complicated to maintain Maybe
uh and then we will go from there uh
once the logic gets a little too
complicated to maintain we might switch
over to doing some cool render stuff all
of the render stuff I've done before has
been tile based I don't know if I want
to make this tile based or not um yeah
I'll have to think about that for
sure I don't want to commit too much to
the render though because that takes
that's going to take longer so let's get
like some of the simulation stuff going
first and perfect I can tell the stream
is up and is H starting to circulate on
X at the very least the other two take a
little longer to warm
up so let me just remind myself of where
we left
off uh puffer lib environments ocean
MOA I think we had a whole bunch of
really garbage uh scyon
right and we had basic attacks we had
basic damage uh the attacks had to
be just like next to next to the agent
so that's a big limitation we don't have
ranged attack abilities on this and
ranged attack abilities are actually
really obnoxious to do uh with grids
so there's there's definitely that to
think about
um we don't have a direction that the
player is facing we're really missing
quite a bit
here uh and then there's also no ability
to attack
Towers
so in something like this usually the
most important thing is getting like a
smooth uh player controller and like the
smooth basics down uh however I think
that getting that to work is going to
require some form of better renderer
than we have now so we might put that
off just a little bit until we at least
get an idea for where we're going to go
with the
game um I think I want to
start could make the towers attackable
right uh there's some just general code
hygiene that definitely needs to be
done but really everything is going to
be limited by the player the player
controller and
viz so maybe we will actually start with
that you
know maybe we will actually just start
with
that yeah we'll make the agents a little
bit
faster um yeah we'll make the agents a
little bit faster and we'll try to come
up with a little bit of a render
controller type thing
that seems
so let's get the human controller to
work then in order to do
that Ender mode
human we'll probably have to fix a few
things
right yep
uh okay that's just an API thing from
the uh the new we did some uh we made
some
changes to the configuration system so
we're going to have a couple small
properties to fix in order to make all
this work but then we'll actually this
will be fun actually because that sort
of tight development Loop that you get
when you have um you have a renderer and
you're just trying to make like a player
work it's actually very nice and it's
very easy to debug so that should
actually be pretty interesting to watch
and pretty informative and should result
in some good progress on this today so
yeah I actually do like that even though
I was a little hesitant at first because
it's going to take me a little bit to
get it set up but uh I think it's going
to be a very very worthwhile investment
and probably not all that hard as long
as I don't like go try to write a whole
renderer from scratch
let's also get this background stuff out
of the way because it makes the chat
hard to uh hard to read
right that's
good okay so now we just have to update
the renderer for the uh the mooba since
this was borrowed from my grid
continuous grid
project so we've
got agent positions right so there's no
uh there's no concept of agent positions
but we do have self.
agents and then if we go to the client
here client render function this will
now just take
agents
and we'll do uh main R
agents zero
doy
y uh okay that's weird we should have
this should be structured
uh okay something's getting passed wrong
because the the agent should be a
structured a structured data type
discretize and if I look at the render
function we have grid agents actions
discretize so that actually looks
right um am I not passing the
correct agents here if I look for self
dot self. agents oh it's self. players
that's
why agents is a annoying API thing
that's why that
exists welcome I am coding a small MOBA
think like League or DOTA uh from
scratch
for the purposes of use in reinforcement
learning training AI at very very high
speed this is brand new so uh there's
not a ton going on here just yet I just
started this yesterday but the hope is
that by the end of today the next seven
hours or so I'm going to have a high
perf engine that like resembles a mooba
that you can play and that you have the
agents wandering around and that runs it
like I don't know a million steps per
second minimum something like that
yesterday went pretty well uh a little
bit confusing because you know there are
a lot of early decisions to make in a
project like this but it went well it
went well
overall actions of zero could not okay
so this is
somewhere num Pi Zer num
agents well this is not going to work
right this has to be numb agents like
three because there are three different
types of actions here
they're two different movement actions
right
oops could not
broadcast uh okay so the action
space I probably didn't update the
action space
right now the action space actually
looks
fine didn't put array from shape
two into shape
three maybe I'm returning it
wrong that's probably it
right yeah right here
this key up key
down I guess the way that we have a
attack specifi doesn't make it a sense
right
well for now we'll just give it a like a
one or whatever for
attack not enough values to unpack right
because I forgot to delete
this yeah we're going to very quickly
run into the limitations of the grid
engine which is exactly why I wanted to
do this project
I wanted to do this project to see you
know what happens when you get M's that
don't like easily represent as
grids shape
base okay so something weird happened
here we'll
figure oh no this is fine this is just
the uh so this this does work we just
have to render the agent I was
controlling it I could tell when I was
pressing keys that it was responding
correctly all we have to do is uh save
it a little different so
let's just make this actually render for
a reasonable period of
time
and next we have to
see how we can draw the
agents what do I have it drawing
here oh I have it drawing the
puffer yeah yeah so if I just um
if I just copy the asset from the grid
continuous project that I was using
puffer
chars I think it'll actually just
render there we
go look at
this I'm a little puffer red puffer blue
puffer DARS or Towers I
guess and you can explore this little uh
you know this manually painted MOBA map
with three
lanes I don't know what killed me oh the
tower killed me right if I go next to it
yeah yeah Tower kills you okay so that
Tower kills me does this Tower kill me
no this one doesn't cuz this is my tower
so I can go here this is the what is
this this is the I think I might have
done him backwards
no okay somebody will have to tell me if
this is the safe lane or what on bottom
I forget I haven't played DOTA in a
while but this is my tower this is their
T1
Tower okay I actually should take a
screeny of this because this is kind of
cool looking
Twitter helps get the open source work
out
there what is
this I don't know what this
is okay
we'll just post that with no
context oh yeah this guy's
cool guy's the the new ding board higher
right
anyways so now we have a really basic
little renderer um but the render is not
fully set up for the type of stuff that
we we are going to want to do with it
right it's kind of like this grid like
movement and it doesn't like the
character doesn't rotate
reasonably and the really big thing is
that mobas are usually controlled with
the mouse uh that is not something that
we're going to be able to do
unfortunately we're not going to be able
to
have
well okay we might be able to make it
human controlled with a mouse but like
the agent isn't going to be able to move
a mouse around that can't be the way
they interact
with with the
environment
um we could
do we could do attack is at a fixed
range in front of
you right we could do that so you when
you attack it's like a fixed range in
front of
you that's not really quite satisfying
though
right we could do
targeting is
hard this was the problem that I ran
into really early in the development of
neural MMO actually that made neural MMO
really hard so let let me sort of break
down this problem for you um this thing
is the source of all evil in
reinforcement learning because there's
not really a good way to have an agent
specify Mouse actions in a in any sort
of way that they could remotely learn
and having Mouse actions assumes that
you're rendering the environment
that's really really slow we don't want
to render the environment at training so
what we do is we typically use some sort
of local state-based
observations right so like you can see
nearby stuff uh but then if you want to
just not attack something next to you
you want to actually select one of the
things that you can see you start to
need different and more complicated
neural network architectures in order to
accomplish that they're kind of like
entity based architectures where instead
of being able to see a grid around you
you get like a set of different entities
or players that you can see now we could
build towards that direction and try to
come up with like a cool entity type
engine um that's probably going to be
the best thing ultimately it's just
really really
hard I mean I'm kind of down though I'm
kind of down to do this because of all
the stuff I could do in reinforcement
learning it's probably the most high
impact thing
to be doing and there's been one really
good project on this so that I know it
can be done it's just very difficult and
that one specific project is not uh
built in a way that's very easy to use
with other stuff
so screw it let's do it right let's
let's just do it
um first thing we're going to need for
this is we're going to need to just
restructure the attack action and the
format of
observations it can keep a grid for now
it can keep the grid as like a nav mesh
or whatever uh so that it can see
obstacles cuz we're still going to use
the grid for
collisions but maybe we're just going to
use the grid for
collisions and that might just be the
only thing we need the grid for maybe
like AOE targeting or something like
that
can take me a second to figure out how I
want to structure
this um I think that the way that you do
this and I don't need it in the
observations just yet because we're not
going to be training models for a while
I just need to do it in a way that will
be easy to put into the observations
eventually if that makes
sense so let's do
entity observations any particular
neural architecture you have in mind for
the vision problem oh this has been very
well explored uh mainly in my own work
on neural MMO but also in Dota and stuff
the thing that I want to avoid let me
just show you how complicated this can
get if you don't think about it very
very
carefully this is what I am trying to
avoid
is it actually not possible to find yeah
here it
is this is what I'm trying to avoid this
gigantic architecture is the open ai5
model it has less than 200 million
parameters but it just has so much
complexity it's just a beast to deal
with something like
this so I'm trying to make it simpler
than this um you know if I if you come
up with something that this complicated
that's this complicated that makes the
environment too hard for people to use
they just won't use it so we're kind of
constrained on that uh on that factor
alone let me fix this I always forget
that I have to like drag windows so that
they don't cover where my camera
is I also don't like that my mouse goes
behind the camera but I can't really do
anything about
that okay some sort of multimodal
approach yeah you could say it's
multimodal it's really just like I guess
that is the definition of of multimodal
yeah different types of local state data
it's different types of local state
data um we're going to just we're going
to allocate uh this on the grid
side let me
see yes so we're going to allocate on
the the python
side we're going to allocate OBS
players and OBS players is going to be
self. OBS
players
zeros so self. num
need dype do item size * 10 10 * dtype
do item size this is going to go right
up here so this means that you're going
to be able to see 10 players we're going
to allocate this as
bytes and
then this is actually OBS players flat
and then self. OBS players is going to
be from
buffer. viw numpy Rec
array and then we're going to have to
pass this
to uh we're going to have to pass this
to the
yeah okay so now this has access to OBS
players flat we have to add it to the C
environment and this is what's going to
allow us to uh see nearby
there been
where uh this type of a
problem this needs to
be it's is this just a player
star I don't want it to be a player uh
player star I want it to be like a array
of player Star right I don't think you
can do that though cuz it's not a valid
numpy data type you can't map uh I don't
think you can map
this that's
why it's uh it's scon technically not C
so I get C speed but I don't have to to
deal with a lot of a lot of C
Shenanigans how did you learn this I've
been doing reinforcement learning for
the past seven years it was my whole
PhD I work on high performance large
scale simulations and reinforcement
learning really like the simulation part
is not that hard cuz if you think about
it that's just Game Dev and yeah Game
Dev isn't easy but it's also not like
Cutting Edge research
right the hard part is making the game
in a way that makes sense to make it
easy to use with reinforcement learning
and fast that's the hard part so a lot
of this like when I'm just like looking
up and thinking about stuff it's me like
crosschecking things that I know can
potentially go wrong with RL if I do it
weird some is just general engineering
as well though let's not be too too
ridiculous
um so what I want this to be right now
and I'm I'm running into this issue
because I just don't have a data type I
don't think I have a data type that fits
this cleanly
um like this is technically a player
star star I
think game industry for a while then
defense yep very
cool
um I really don't want this to be a
player star star but I think it has to
be for
now I think
CNP this shouldn't be a player star star
I have love for rust for scon though I'm
learning rust now I have not seen the
point of rust remotely for any of my
work the main thing that Russ gives you
is memory safety I literally do not need
to maloc anything in this Sim everything
is fixed allocation if you're maling
stuff you're being
slow so the main feature that Russ gives
you is not something I need
and all it does is going to get all it
will do is get in my way with a borrow
Checker that is you know not
needed this the thing is what this thing
the thing that's giving me uh rust has a
kickass
logo we got a we got a puffer
fish what I want this to do is I want
this to be like uh like a player array
or
something but you can't do that because
it has to be
a specific memory view type
right view the
puffer puffer is very
friendly all you got to do is feed the
puffer a star on GitHub otherwise puffer
gets hungry you don't want the puffer to
be
hungry okay
uh I'm going to just make this a player
star for now and see what happens I have
no idea what this will do
it
compiles um if I run this does it
crash trial and errors is the basis of
learning yeah you'd be surprised how
much of the time it's just I don't know
what this will do I'm going to play with
it for the next few hours and then I'll
probably be able to get it to work and
the skill just comes in knowing enough
things that you can get it to work in
you know the next few hours instead of
the next few
months okay so this did not break
anything at the very least it still runs
rling yourself yeah
seriously
um I think that this might be a bad
pointer cast is the
thing well I know how I can do it for
sure
technically I know how I can do it for
sure I don't get any memory bounce any
error bounce checking or anything
but it compiles as their worst
result
look if the key feature of rust were not
this borrow Checker that I don't need
and that gets in my way like I literally
have no need for this thing this thing
adds so much baggage and I just do not
need it right I do not need the selling
point of it yeah it's a very
well-engineered language and there's a
lot of great stuff it's just I wish that
the all the effort were not being put
into something that very very many
applications do not need right which is
the the memory
safety very very low down on the list of
problems what I really like about
cython um in addition to these memory
views and compatibility with python is
that I have all these compile time
checks that I can just switch on and off
so I can make make my Dev super fast and
I can actually get some reasonable error
messages um and I can just you know turn
them all off uh when I am ready to make
it
fast my parallel
programming have you seen poer Leb we
have lots and lots of parallel
programming we have actually the best
the best CPU multiprocessing
implementation out there for
reinforcement
learning and uh it's just python and a
bunch of shared memory
Shenanigans cool to see people finding
the stream on Twitch though and no
discoverability is harder there for new
stuff okay so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to do the thing that I know is
going to work for now so that I'm not
here experimenting forever because
that's going to be really boring um
the thing that I know will work is just
treating this as a flat array of players
and then writing a function to get the
specific player that I need uh for you
know what whatever
thing and this is actually going to be a
class
function YouTube after a college
football 25 video I have no idea how
that possible because I've not
had done I've have not had any
engagement with football in my life
whatsoever I'm using
algorithm idx so we're going to get uh
self and this is a c Def and this is
going to return a player
star get player OB
turn PID
times going to be 10 times PID we hard
code for now plus
idx this is
fine so now we have access to this uh
observation and when we compute
observations we need to uh do something
about this so
this is going to add a lot of you know
slowdown to this but we can optimize
later the thesis vid I
swear well it's funny because did you
get you didn't find the thesis vid on TW
on Twitch right unless I guess you found
it from somewhere else
um I'm going to probably try to make
another couple of long form videos to
see if it was just like a onetime thing
or uh if people actually will you know
like the Deep dive technical content cuz
there are a few other things I can do I
have an idea for one on just puffer lib
in general that's like an RL primer of
sort of how I see the whole landscape of
reinforcement learning right now and
what are the major problems that need to
be solved for us to move forward as a
field and I can make that pretty
accessible and uh I also have one on
some of the Sim Tech that I've been
thinking about
transferred from YouTube twitch was hard
to find link is on the YouTube page some
mentioned that it was the same as your
ex yeah well I'm technically I'm live on
uh Twitter Youtube and twitch so it
really doesn't matter where where you
watch it right as long as there're
people somewhere and I can see the
metrics now on the only one I can't see
is I can't see concurrent views on uh
Twitter Twitter only tells you total
views it doesn't tell you concurrent
viewers
okay so what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to find all of the agents that are
in a crop around the current agent and
I'm going to load them into uh this
observation buffer yeah that's how I'm
going to try to do this
and does this
solve we're going to have to do mouse
based actions I guess for
we're going to have to do mouse based
actions for the human
client hey Will
welcome I honestly I got this idea from
you you were the only other person I saw
ever streaming Dev so I figured hey why
not instead of letting will have all the
fun you know co-opting agents with uh
with gp4 why don't we make some uh some
real RL agents that have like a million
parameters
here I'll show you something cool
scale-wise from uh last night so I got
carbs working this is like well over 50
billion uh simulation steps worth of
data in one experiment overnight on one
GPU and it like this with carbs hyper
pram sweep this just kicked ass this
like beat of my manually tuned baselines
by a huge margin um just essentially
Auto solves your environments this model
has like 150,000 parameters but it
trains at a million steps per second so
who
data
anyways um this thing here so I need to
figure
out uh the PID I think in this
position need to read carb stuff dude I
can't read the carbs paper it's too much
math okay I understand that they did
some Pito optimality front thing on top
of basian optimization and that's it uh
I did integrate it with puffer lib
though so I got that going for me which
is
nice carbs is
awesome sucker for data
quantity okay here's another cool stat
right this is why I think RL is really
cool and a lot of people don't
necessarily get this um you know coming
from NLP so NLP like these giant
Transformers with like thousands of
hunds right they're trained on order of
terabytes maybe tens of terabytes of
data it's trillions of tokens right
token is like an INT four bytes
something like that maybe you can pack
it into a short depending um that's the
amount of data like we can go through
that in a day on a GPU one GPU in
reinforcement learn learning so just the
data scale is so crazy with
RL um and there's been a little bit of
theoretical work showing that RL scales
way better with data than with model
size at least for a while so you need
way more data to saturate any fixed
model size so actually doing this High
perf Sim and high perf uh High perf
engineering work it really makes a huge
difference
equals H did I mess this up do I need
another variable
here I think this is DX
right
Dy d y DX
do you have a preferred
GPU uh I have I've got the puffer
cluster this is the puffer cluster right
here we've got eight desktops with 409s
in them this is where the experiments
all
run uh these two up top these run my own
experiments this one is a colleague of
mine friend who was using it for another
cool RL
and then these five right here are all
dedicated to open source training on
Pokemon Red trying to get RL to solve
Pokemon Red and then this is like an old
this is an old box I'm using as a login
node and this is a puffer
cluster very economical compared to an
LP land
don't need this don't need this check um
now what we need to do is we get the
PID in
PID PID is going to be equal to PID map
at y and x and then if it is let's do if
PID equals negative 1 you
continue otherwise we do
we get the
observation at PID and
Target is going to be equal to get
player
OB and we need to figure
out where the data is for that
so
uh I think it's
actually Target equals to self. get
player PID and then you have to load it
into and you copy the contents of one
struct into
another that's a good question
um I know how you do it from the python
side I wonder if I can just use the
colon like the bracket
indicator I don't know the Syntax for
this it should technically be something
like self. get player
OB
like Target something like
this I'm sure this doesn't
compile let's
see invalid index for memory view
specified well this needs to be R I
guess
C thoughts on
number in a lot of benchmarks it beats
scon that's just people gaming
benchmarks like thing that generates C
code is thing that generates C code it's
just how good your C code is and uh it
depends on what you're using
you absolutely cannot do the stuff I'm
doing at the moment with number
though this is a bit more than just
jitting your
it well it doesn't seem to crash and it
would be running this
code so maybe this is actually the
correct maybe you can actually do this
that'd be sweet if you could if this is
all it takes to assign a struck to a
struck that's
awesome let's just uh let's get on to
the interesting stuff here
so we now have a way to get the
players
into uh into
this which will give you a way to do
attacks but I'm still going to have to
do something with the uh the client like
you'd have to be able to click them I
think is there any other way I can do
this without like
so let's do um
maybe let's figure out if there's a way
to do Clicks in uh in
rayb Clicks in like health bars maybe
that would be a decent spot to start
that'll be pretty interesting I'd say
and that'll help us
out okay so we need to be able to like
get mouse input I
guess from this
yeah let's
do mouse RB
mouse mouse
input they just have an is mouse button
pressed
they don't have coordinates
though oh wait get mouse
position so that's fine we can just do
get mouse
position uh it's probably is it X Y or Y
like it's probably XY
X Mouse Y is get mouse
position Mouse X Mouse
Y and then what we'll do is we will edit
the actions
here
um we'll edit the actions to
be something
this is so difficult to think about how
to
represent that's the problem with
this it's very difficult to think about
how to represent the mouse Clicks in a
way that's going like it's easy to think
about how to represent actions for
agents or how to represent actions for a
game it's hard to do both at the same
time I mean the input mode of the the
input mode of um
the agent is going to be different so I
think that the best thing we can do is
just
convert right here
maybe is we just do the calc in
yeah okay
so let's we'll have to what we're going
to have to do is we're going to have to
set this to 10 which is the number of
agents that it can see and then we're
going to rewrite the the C code just a
little bit so that the targeting is
based off of uh nearby
agents
so it does
step and then there's the tower thing
and then where's the
attack okay so here's the adjacent
attack code we're going to change this a
little bit um so this is a
attack ID I
guess
and we need to store the the ID I uh we
need to store the ID of the agent that
we are potentially
attacking
so I like this lesson
less but have to do it
let's just add like
in
attack uh and this is the now this is
not the PID but we can get PID equal to
do we have PID
defined yeah we have PID
defined so we can get PID equal
player agent idx and
then
attack
no get player OB okay so the target so
the way that this works is you have the
attack the attacks is the index of the
agent that you can see that is nearby
you then we get your observation of that
player uh by looking at your index and
then the attack
offset and
then we get the PID of the target as
target.
PID right and then if the pit is
design pit is negative
one continue
we can't do this continue because
there's more stuff down here right
welcome yeah doesn't really matter which
platform people watch on whatever is
most convenient for you
I think the
uh I don't know how it works I think
it's like whichever if you have twitch
turbo then you don't get ads on Twitch
and if you have YouTube premium you
don't get ads on YouTube and I think you
just don't get ads on X no maybe you
need X premium to not get ads or maybe
you just never get ads but the quality
is always 720p I don't know whatever you
guys like the most um I have not set any
ads that are not mandated by the
platform forms
so okay so if the pit is not equal to
negative one then we need to do the
attack which
okay so this probably is good and then
we need to just work on the data
structure a little
bit coding MOBA from scratch are you a
single Dev on this project yeah I
started this yesterday um and hopefully
this is not going to take particularly
long either we're going to see this is
not meant to be like a super fun MOA for
people this is like a strip down MOBA
that we're going to use for
reinforcement learning and the main
technical complexity of this project is
making it relatively easy to use with
reinforcement learning and making it run
it like a million steps per second these
are things that I know how to
do year I I'm a year 12 State student
11th grade for us basic knowledge in the
field of machine learning I was
wondering if you had any advice get more
experience with AI and ml uh that's
pretty much when I started it took a lot
of work programming resources beginner
projects I should do
uh you definitely want to learn basic
like core programming that's very very
important to do uh and you're going to
want to do that in a way that is fun and
does not bore you I got very very bored
very very quickly with my courses and I
just started doing a ton of projects so
I generally advise new people to spend
like 90% of their time maybe if you're
really new like 80% of your time doing
projects that you find fun very small
scope stuff that you can finish and uh
20% of your time on like formal learning
uh a lot of the stuff nowadays is on
YouTube uh the best resources for AI and
ml are
cs231n the videos for that are uh online
it is a grad course but is a relatively
accessible graduate
course um
and yeah outside of that it's it's a lot
of like I might I may have some things I
can point you to that will save you some
time here and there if you ask specifics
but there is just a huge time investment
to learn this stuff I started around
that age I spent like I don't know
probably 2,000 hours joint with
everything else I was doing in my first
year and a half like just getting the
very very Basics and uh I mean I've been
doing it from there ever since for the
last 10
years but you know you do get
there and really I think that the
biggest skill difference in
uh in a lot of places in AI is not like
hard math or anything that's really
difficult to wrap your head around it's
just being a very good
engineer like the best thing that I do
that lets me do what I do here like yeah
there's a crucial science piece of it
that's very hard to go get without and
they like yeah there's a little bit of
math but it's just trying to be very
good at making very complicated things
simple and just being very very
persistent about trying to like write
good code uh to make complicated things
simple um and that comes more from just
having things being complicated
bothering you a lot than
anything this code is not an example of
good code don't do as I say not as I do
this is shitty prototype
code and this is me trying to do things
quickly on stream because otherwise it's
very boring watching me like stare at if
statement for an hour trying to think if
I can save five
lines okay so we needed to fix the uh
the compute observations functions right
so what we do here is I think that this
is self
dot we have to clear self. player OBS
for this is it is still good though
seconde college students that just got
really interested machine learning too
is it better invest in Hardware or run
the program on cloud uh I'm not going to
tell you how to spend your money um and
it depends on what you're trying to do
uh a good desktop for reinforcement
learning specifically a good desktop
takes you pretty far the one thing is
that for most environments you want to
have a pretty nice CPU that can keep up
with the GPU um if I were looking to
build like a budget thing uh
actually can I no I can't move the
camera uh I have a little mini ITX next
to me on the desk that I'm using for
this that has a 3080 and an 8 core
processor I'd probably go for at least a
12 core
processor um if I were going to you know
go for like a little budget build uh you
there's also the like the higher end
stuff that I I've shown on my uh my site
where is it this is what I use this is
the exact Hardware I use to run my stuff
but these boxes are like four grand a
piece um you can build something decent
for like half that or less to get
started the cloud instances on vast are
fine uh but like mentally it's really
obnoxious to like think about having to
spin something up every time and like
knowing that you're constantly draining
the budget on that so I've always liked
having my Hardware but uh you know you
can kind of do either definitely don't
go with like Google cloud or something
that will suck that will just sap all
your money very quickly
I think actually I just need this right
I just set the pit and then the rest of
it can be garbage for
now yeah this is
fine uh and
we
do if
idx1
Rak ah such
garbage so there's like all this check
this checking and stuff I have to do to
make sure I'm not overfilling these
buffers these are raw pointers so
technically like if I screw this up I'm
just going to get seg fols and I'm going
to be confused I think
oh I should have mentioned that the
answer was really for um RL specifically
for broader ml like if you're trying to
do Transformers you're kind of just
screwed um yeah that's like that that's
just it it's not affordable even for
me to do like heavy stuff with
NLP if you're doing stuff outside of RL
with like you know medium small size
models for applications then you just
want the best GPU you can get and that's
basically
RAM I'm pretty happy with my stack for
RL
though oh geez Google cloud is so
stupidly expensive you will pay the
entire cost of your Hardware uh in two
months so you used Google Cloud for two
months you've basically bought the
machine machine and their machines are
interesting oh right so we had to we got
to do some stuff in Python on the python
side
cool Dory that the stream is warming up
though
um kind of funny to me that people like
watching random Dev but hey works for
right this mapping is kind of
hard not going to
lie what if I just punt on this for now
right what if I just like hardcode this
to zero I think this will just be the
first that you can see if I hardcode to
zero for
now let's see if it works or if it
crashes so this is what I was warning
about this is one of the places where
like I wish cython had way more tooling
investment but because I'm using a
buffer
here I have to be very careful not to
overrun any of my
buffers otherwise you get no Reon a
error message even with syon checks
10 well first of
all this is idx has to be incremented so
I shouldn't be overrunning
it is a nice background signal during my
own Dev I don't know how you Focus
listening to this but hey it's pretty
learn it's 10 then you break if it's 10
then you
break but this wasn't it because we
weren't incrementing
idx it could be this
what if I just pass here to
something it could also be on the other
side it could be on the um the
computation of attacks I wouldn't be
surprised
okay so it's still seg fals meaning that
it's not this um I think it's probably
right here
somewhere so get player
OB agent
index and then the
um and then you do get player of the
target pit
Target okay so print this and let's do
got
Target maybe it's here
did it segul before anything
happened just checking when you
mentioned
cs231n deep learning for computer yeah
but it covers more than just computer
vision um go find either like Andre's
original lectures carpy's lectures or
like Justin's lectures some of the
lectures are better than others the
video should be pretty old at this point
but they're very good uh the main thing
about that course compared to many of
the other ones is that you will have a
decent chance of following a lot of it
uh some of the other grad courses are
just very math heavy for no apparent
reason like you're not going to unless
you have a very good grad math
background you're not going to be able
to follow cs229 for instance and it's
not going to be particularly useful so
that's really the the good one that's
there
very weird that we're not even getting
here that we're just seg faulting
right I know I'm just going to add some
prints we're going to be lazy
here I really wish we had a better
debugger for this
happened well that doesn't make sense to
me that it's it's seg faulting before
it's printing
anything I guess it would have to be on
the compute observations huh
is scon as good as other
options so for this particular
project like what other options would
there be it would either be write it in
C++ and then nobody will ever bother
reading the source code and it will be a
pain and I have to deal with
pbind or like anything else I have to
basically deal with annoying like cross
language
interfaces um sion's the only thing that
bypasses like pbind like annoyances with
signatures and the like and that has a
decent chance of being read and used by
researchers because it's basically just
python
um yeah there there's really nothing
else I could think of that would be good
I mean I guess there's some new stuff
around but nothing that really fits this
profile did it not give me did I just
forget to recompile it no how is it seg
falting
before Oh wait here it is so resetting
buffers yeah so it's failing here
somehow resetting buffers for OBS
4 get player
OB oh okay so yeah this function is just
not working the way that I'm expecting
that's fine yeah that's we kind of
expected to do this so this is one of
the limitations here uh what I would
like to have is I would like to have
an array of player
star or mem view of player
star I can't really do that
right I mean maybe because it's a se
struct you can I don't think you can
here let me let me see if I try to
compile this as
like
player array player OBS this won't work
right
wait are you actually allowed to do this
am I just being
dumb so I have errors but I don't have
errors on this data
type if you can do this this is
sweet we'll try it we will uh we will
try
it cannot convert player to a memory
view
slice
um well you wouldn't have to right you
would just
do I doubt this is going to work but if
it does it actually makes our life way
easier probably write a small test
function you
know you're probably right I hate
writing tests but that would be easier
wouldn't it
let me go find there's a Syntax for
importing scyon
files um I forget where it is I think I
have an example in clean pop
RL yeah so right
here technically I can do
that's probably a nice thing to have
because this is a complicated project so
we're probably going to want to be able
to test some stuff
right
import test struct
whatever test struct
Moa so I want this like player D type
this type of a code right
ITX why why does it do this to
me okay you know whatever super Maven
will just do
it
nope I did not tell to auto
complete yeah I love it once when yeah
player and
PID now it'll do it
right yeah now that just does
it CP
death okay there it
works dumb very dumb
let's check the Twitter real quick to
see if there's anything on
it I do have to uh see if there's any
cool stuff going
on H some
follows no uh no cool comments on wait
okay just
refreshed see it fallen out
uh okay nothing
thesis defense was really cool presented
really well too thank you looking
forward to your developments I've done
more in the last two months than I've
done in the last two years actually the
progress has been absolutely insane with
puffer lib
um it's just like as soon as the
academic side got out of my way and I
don't have to think about papers and I
can just focus on like good highper
engineering stuff has started moving
really really fast like I'm very very
happy with how puffer be shaping
up okay so what we were trying to do is
we were trying to figure out
we want player dtype and then test
struct maybe player dtype
have I
seen.
0481 one
I think puffer lib should have a first
class oh was this the thing that was on
Twitter
wait is this new was this the thing that
was on
Twitter so I saw the thing on
Twitter
experiments I'm always so distrustful of
algorithm results
man clean RL DQ yeah I'm so distrustful
of algorithm
results um I've seen just I've wasted
way too much of my time um like you know
trying to like go like use new
algorithms and stuff and the comparisons
are just always always bad faith
comparisons like for instance I know
that the um the clean RL defaults are
horribly horribly wall clock inefficient
so like this type of a plot here this is
not remotely representative like I
guarantee you they did not tune this
Baseline um or use like remotely
reasonable settings I have this video
that's pinned to my Twitter where I make
like clean RL first I make it like four
times faster as a comparison to the
Baseline I optimize that and then I make
puffer like two or three times faster on
top of
that well I'm not using rainbow dqn
right like I'm using PPO as my basis for
everything at the moment
and is this
simple very low
memory only algorithm is
po lower number of hyper
parameters and provable
stability provable stability
I don't know about
that this is not exactly
true and did they
discount so the thing with puffer is I'm
not actually puffer is not primarily in
an algorithms Library if you've noticed
I only have I have one implementation in
puffer um puffer is fast compatible M
support like you could use puffer with
this whatever their code is if it has a
VEC interface for like Gym's you can use
puffer with their thing and puffer will
just instantly make this thing two to
three times faster bare minimum
sometimes 10 times faster for certain
environments um
at the very least like more algorithm
implementations is bottom of my priority
list because people have been doing this
forever like there are a million
different algorithm
implementations and thus far nothing has
stood the test of time over
po maybe this will be the thing that's
different and I do like that they have
craft a as a baseline that's that's very
nice
um it actually if you look at it it's
it's about the same here which is funny
that they just have this different curve
shape that's very
interesting
um
yeah they need to run this for longer as
well craftex you can get way more than a
billion frames
on and then these are like tiny there's
so much stuff I can show like here for
instance this overcooked environment
they have like one E6 time steps cuz
this environment is so slow I messed
with this and the code base for this
environment is just God awful like this
environment should run at a million
steps per second and instead it runs at
like I don't know a hundred or a few
hundred um
yeah so like I would I don't even trust
this environment fundamentally because
of what a mess it is
uh smacks I'm not familiar with hanabe
okay
cool
yeah one10 is nice but these are you
know the very similar for these Ms I
don't know we'll see my general policy
with algorithms is I wait to see if they
stick around and if people actually like
them and then I look at them because
I've literally wasted months before on
things that looked promising like uh the
dreamer V3 paper for instance that
looked super promising right well turns
out not really wasted 10,000 compute
hours on
it maybe some sort of dqn based thing
maybe for
so data G
type yeah let let's get back to coding
this thing
Okay so we've got this
now and then we have
cdef
layers
uh let's do
name
okay we
have right we have to import
numpy if this works it'll be very
awesome I think it's pretty unlikely
that it does um and then I'm going to
have to rethink a bunch of stuff if it
do
test.py if I go here and I try to
populate this with
equals what is it it's uh nump
dot no wait how do you do this again
yeah you have to
do D type. item
size and then it's like equal numpy
doint
8 and then it's going to be like data
struct data is going to
be from
buffer of data no not
view view wreck
this spend a lot of time on data types
here yeah so it's from buffer with the D
type. view Rec
array uh and then what we do is we do
struct
data dox equals nump a range 10 + three
or plus yeah three so now we have
something to look
at um
test Ah that's interesting so yeah you
can't
do you can't do it like this obviously
so it's going to be
50 uh
dot let's do like one
51 that reshape 10
broadcast into input from shape 105 into
shape 50 why
this not
the is this not the shape that I think
it
is if we can use this as the data
structure back end for our environment
it's going to be very
50 we should be able to dot like reshape
right do reshape 105 Maybe
something buffer has the wrong number of
dimensions
expected
two got
oops how do I do this here need to do
dot data
pointers let me Google this real quick
just to see if there's an
obvious uh
memory slice of rock syon let me just
see if there's a thing for this
Dimensions I think you need to give it
the right number of bites
maybe let's see if we give this the
right number of bites right here
does it say
expected expected two Dimensions got
three dimensions is that what it
said why does it
expect two
Dimensions when it is a struct
uh 2D
typed memory view of struct
now now this is the opposite
problem 2D Plus plus memory
views struct definition array of memory
view nope this
is not what we're looking
for um
you can technically create it from the
scon side I'd rather not do that
though struct definition with typed
memory view as member
no when you want to assign this to a
struct
right I don't want to cast it to a
pointer
something I think even a 1D so if I just
do like this I cut 2D I think I can
generalize it type memory view
what I'm trying to do here is I'm trying
to
get this
data I'm trying to make this into a 2d
array of strs so this extra Dimension
here should get crunched into the
struct but for some reason it's not it
is not
cooperating and I can't find docks on
how to do this but it does look like
it's
supported I thought I'd seen a post that
was
like reasonable before
array of
structs like to fill a long array of
strs from
this hold the character
array way to do this in
syon doesn't like mixing arrays with
scalar
arrays well this one has without a
cast so here they passed a structured
array and then they just assign
it so what if I do it this way what if I
pass the structured array right
um I can do that right I can do struct
data Maybe This does it maybe that
actually would save me some if this
worked that would actually make it
easier ooh this looks like it does
work
so and I'm learning more and more about
um the way to do stuff with syon and
it's getting like increasingly Compact
and
Powerful let's see see what this why
this doesn't like
it cannot take the address of a memory
slice
okay cannot convert player slice to
player
star that's fine
full
interesting let's uh let's do it right
like this C
def player star player pointer
it's going to be like
this and again we cast and then we print
player pointer dot
xes this give me an
enough where is it I need more
background on this
where is
the the history of
it can I seriously not set the scroll
history on this
am I just not seeing it I could have
sworn I said this just the other
day green buffer
no cannot convert point to a pointer
type that might have
worked yeah yeah so that's it so now do
I get the full error
message this should give me the full
error
okay so this
is yeah it's giving me an internal
error which is kind of weird because
this should be able to be converted to a
pointer type
right oh I think I know what it is
um you just do
it's
player star
player address of 0 0
right and then you get to print player
dox I think that's how it works
value right because this is giving us an
individual player
is I'm overthinking
this I only need vectorized
access from the python side because I'm
going to be writing Loops in scon
anyways so the way that you would do
this is just like
now we get out of bounds because I uh I
went well because I went out of
bounds but this is very nice because
this will actually give you bounce
checks and stuff so I won't get any more
seg
fults so I did not know that you could
do
this this actually simplifies my scon a
whole
lot I mean you still have to CL you
still have to
you still have to cast it to a
pointer
but it's a lot
easier
okay so let's go do this for the main
MOA and this is going to simplify stuff
a lot actually going to be very
nice it's kind of annoying that I'm like
doing all these syon projects and only
discovering these things later
on because it means I'm going to have to
go back to all my earlier code and like
reformat it like this because this is so
much better
right so all we have to do is we do
self. players
equals numpy
num
agents
10 D type is going to be dtype
don't need this mess
right and then self do
creeps uh we don't need op creeps we
just do creeps like
this Towers is going to just be zeros
again so much
easier so so much easier
environment we just have to pass the
regular versions we no longer need these
flattened annoying
copies and then we get to make stuff
memory views instead of pointers memory
views are way nicer to work with than
pointers
oops way way nicer
so this player star is now a player
array player memor view
rather and then this player OBS is now a
player double M view like this 2D M View
and then we have creeps and
towers
and you literally don't even need the
cast
anymore and you don't even need the dot
data anymore it's literally just this
simple that's actually incredible
so your entity component system just got
like I used to have to say hey it's kind
of hard to set up the entity component
system you know you got to do a little
bit of memory management you got to do a
little bit of stuff and now it's just
trivial now it's just
trivial we're going have to rewrite a
couple very uh very small functions here
like this git
player looks more simplified
yeah um there definitely some rough
edges on scon but the more I use it the
more I find stuff like this it's really
really nice what it gives you I mean
this is a trivial entity component
system that is shared memory between
Python and scyon so you can do highle
ops that are not performance critical in
Python you know you can do your array
Ops or whatever and then you can do your
performance critical stuff in syon and
it runs at c-s speed and all the changes
are immediately reflected to python
without pbind without anything it's just
very transparent and lightweight
so we no longer have to do this array
map it's just player OBS PID idx we
still have to remember this and Pand
otherwise it'll copy but this is the
only little bit of
because since it's a m view of player
you can still get the
fix and the real nice big advantages of
um instead of using a pointer uh like
just a pointer type to represent what is
actually an array of pointers right cuz
that's what you do you know charar is a
string it's just you just keep reading
it now since we have a memory view we
actually get bounds checking which means
it's actually impossible for us to Segal
on uh on any of these data structures
which is very very nice for debugging
and Dev in
general so we didn't just fix the bug
from before
we made it literally
impossible for that bug to
exist and now we get reasonable errors
so we go fix some
errors but they're like easy non-
terrible errors
right um so there is still the matter of
casting to a Rec array
right we do still need to cast to a Rec
array
H I wonder if I just pass it as a Rec
Ray if it's still fine
fine okay so we still get a seg fault
here we do have some data types that are
not
bounce
checked or do we let me
see where did we have those print
statements from before
very weird that we
are I mean we might be getting these
Tech pts on a knit
right like maybe this
um maybe it do doesn't know how to deal
with the rec
array where's the first one we assign is
it right
here setting up
arrays print
setup
Players let's see if this
prints it's probably seg fting on the
setup code actually
so I want to not just fix this seg fold
I want to figure out where it's coming
from and then restructure whatever piece
of code that is so it's impossible to
get Segal
a for some reason we actually it didn't
seg fold immediately and we got a
reasonable
error which is from get player of
PID so that is interesting
uh so we have that this thing here can
potentially uh be out of
bounds this target
PID so we'll figure that out let me see
if uh it always does
this yeah so no now we NE now we still
get a
Segal and we get the
Segal we get the Segal very
early I don't know how that's possible
in
it how do we how's it possible to get a
Segal before we've done
anything well that's bizarre
right that we're getting a seg
fault is it possible we're getting it
from like somewhere else from RB or
tile how is it that we're getting to
render but we're not getting to anit the
environment
right is it clearing oh oh I think it's
clearing the
um I think it's
clearing yeah yeah yeah so if I just put
like here
go okay so this is actually fine um it
does reset
correctly and then it's going to
clear later on so let's just
do
clear uh pulse
clearing oh I just have a clear in the
system don't
I not this one
yeah os. system clear right here so I
was just clearing the data we should
probably not have that set that way for
debugging okay perfect so now we see
that you do tile one tile One Source wck
uh then it
crashes
so I want to see if it gets to the end
of the render Loop
no it does not get to the end of the
render Loop that means something that is
happening in the render Loop is crashing
it is quite
odd
um this render Loop
goes R Min our
Max the only thing you're accessing here
is G isn't
it I mean I actually it could be RB
ulting
corrupted size versus prev
size
H
grid not out of bounding the
grid size versus PR size what if I just
don't draw this does it still
tile can I just run it non-human
mode if I run
this uh so now we actually we get the
same error but we don't get this egg B
python
Malik it's very weird because I'm not
malaking
anything unsigned
long unsigned long
failed was this happening before I cast
to recar
Ray if I
do Players
recck players. viw let's just try this
to see cuz it's possible that it's just
the memory views don't know how to
handle i' say it's even fairly likely
that the memory views just don't know
how to handle this
right and I actually think that this
would be you go back
to players what is
this
see see
players so up
players C OBS players
players and let's just
uh the
creeps
okay and then we pass the C1
creeps okay and then we pass the C1 to
syon C
players see OBS
players nope
I don't know why it's uh it's so
insistent on totally messing everything
up bad bad
suggestions
you
right puffer mooba has no attribute
players help up
we do
have this is supposed to be C
players the OBS
Towers we still get this weird
Malik thing and we just remember we
tested this is correct before
getting player OBS
9 well maybe we can track it down
now getting player OBS
n reset
buffers computed
observations
observation rebuild this oops
so it looks like it's happening on the
attacks
potentially because it computes all the
observations we have a very easy way to
confirm this we can just comment out the
attack
Loop and
see what is potentially happening in
there remember this shouldn't be able to
Segall
computed
observations segmentation
fault it doesn't even get to the start
up here right
render is it it's resetting correctly
though
right no it's not resetting correctly
point okay so it's it's delaying the it
the problem is in
reset it looks like
happens even though it says it computed
all the
okay so if I comment out compute
observations uh it actually works and it
it gets through the first step until I
assume it gets to compute observations
again so if I comment out both compute
observations right
I'm assuming that this will just
work and somewhere there's a seg fold in
compute observations that I'm
missing which could just be like weird
undefined behavior that is not cropping
up until
later okay so yes this does in fact work
the Segal is somewhere in compute
observations so let's just go figure out
what the heck
I broke over
there so even though that is technically
printing through all of
this I bet you it's this line right here
not working the way I think it
is let's just guess
yeah so it is this
line so I don't know what this line is
doing but it's not doing what I was
intending to do
um get player
here so get player OB hold
on get player op gives you a player
star how do I copy one struct into
another into
syon there C
syntax you can assign from one to the
other yeah this is a shallow copy so
this
is not what I wanted
I'm going to do it the dumb way for now
that I know will
OB uh so we're going to do Target OB is
going to be this and then we do Target
ob. PID Target ob. X Target ob. y Target
ob. health and Target ob.
team we're just going to copy the
properties individually
okay and now this works as
intended and we
have a very nice representation of our
data
we have a very
nice uh ability now to start building
the attack
operations I think we potentially have
some out of bounds stuff in
here uh we will see when I build this
okay this actually runs without seg
folting or or anything weird already
that's
nice we'll do uh where is it render
mode
human and uh why don't we add like some
health bars and stuff
right so here's our better rendered
version of this environment we can
control our little
puffer and uh we probably don't want to
get too close to the tower because it
will Merc
you and we can move in eight directions
movement could be smoother you know we
can do some potentially other stuff uh
particularly this movement of enemies
looks very
choppy we could potentially render that
continuous instead of
discreet actually wouldn't that be
ridiculously easy to
do hold on I think that's like
ridiculously easy to do isn't
it uh it's not going to make a
difference for now though because we
have the speed set to CLI we have the
speeds clipped but in the future we will
actually be able to do it that
way because we do have the position
saved as FL
right we're going to need to get
the player
IDs and the like in order to do all of
this I do wonder if it would be easier
for us
to the player ID thing
works I wish we could just store like
right the fundamental difficulty in this
project comes from this mix of having
like a grid representation for things
that need to be
computed uh over things that are nearby
because a grid is more efficient for
that
and having to have a representation for
um well everything
well for now we can just expose the uh
the player IES and that will be
sufficient to get us some health bars
right so what we're going to do is this
grid here self.
pids going to be zeros with a 30 in
32 and then it we'll just pass this pids
to
CM right here
uptp
pids Ste
MOA this will now take
grid
be
pids we have to remember to subtract one
ni
one and now we have access to
pids
so in the render function
here what we can actually do
is's
grid yeah we need pids as well now pids
right pids grid PS
agents
there let's do
grid s.
pids okay so now what we do is we're
going to do PID it's going to be pids
of uh the p
position and the position is going to
be use an inj here
for see we've got main
R when you finish why don't you upload
this on get as an open source so
everyone can contribute to this to
something
um all of my work is immediately
uploaded to get as open source this is
in puffer lib already it's in one of the
it's in like a random Dev branch that
I've been trying to like merge
technically it's in any config so
everything up until this morning is
already there and then you know as soon
as I get to a stable spot I'll you know
I'll be making commits throughout the
day so yeah all of my stuff is
immediately open source and you're more
than welcome to submit PRS discuss stuff
on discord.gg Puffer and otherwise
contribute to the project that's the
name of the game
r yeah so I mean
it's I mean if you want to look at my
track record of open sourcing stuff um
so neural MMO is the thing that I've
worked on for the last like seven years
before this uh this is the Discord this
is the repository right here literally
all of my work from the last how however
many years all the way from 10 is open
source all of puffer lib so the thing
that I'm building now full-time all of
puffer give it a star if you would is uh
open source from you know 01 wherever 01
is in here I guess O2 is the first thing
um that's all open source and all the
dev branches even are open source uh I
generally don't have cloth Source stuff
there are a couple like side things I'm
working on that I don't want to just
announce just yet so that it'll be you
know cooler when I finally show it off
but uh I think I'm going to be doing
less and less of that in the future I
think it's going to really just be
everything immediately open source um
because that's been working really well
for me so yeah we're definitely looking
for more people to get involved with
this type of stuff because I can only do
so much you know I'm one guy
code okay so now we have the
PID um
um which should not be negative one so
if
PID one
raise
PID
um and then we're going to do
so was it
player equals
player yeah player is going to be equal
to players
PID or is it agents agents
PID health is going to be player
Health uh and then when we draw this
this
texture what we're going to do is let's
see if super Maven will do it draw a
health bar
heck oh I see what it's trying to
do Max wait Min Health yeah it just
needs to be
three it's just health over
three don't need this and then this is
red then this is what black
green wait no wait
R did this
backwards
wait wait TS Times health bar yeah this
should be
green let's see if the health bars work
probably have to debug a couple things
buffer has wrong number of
Dimensions expected two got one
pids uh
well yeah that would make sense this is
health. height health. width minus one
uh well this is passing the correct
Dimensions now
right
HS to
PS I not save the
file oh yeah I guess I just hadn't saved
the file
perfect okay so now we have an out of
bounds
main R plus
r uh it shouldn't be possible for there
to be an out of bounds here
actually yeah that should not be
possible cuz this is drawing
around the central agent
so in that case I'm
assuming that I'm using the wrong number
somewhere
here but I don't see where that would
be R
Min our Max
uh and then what's
this r
uh try printing every time yeah I just
did so it's there's some crazy value for
uh RNC right now I'm trying to see if I
over Road those values anywhere I don't
see it
though this is not inside of a
loop why would R be
enumerate range R Min and R Max yeah
that doesn't make any sense to me
um I think I'm going to move this down
because this is you can't put break
points inside of the ray draw Loop
because
it's Raab does some magic under the hood
for that but I can put a loop here and I
can say
height
what
huh oh I don't use um I'm not using R
here at all right
okay yeah I I wrote some really Jank
Loops here uh it's just supposed to
be yeah it's just supposed to be
R so that's
fine so it's just supposed to be R and
C this is what happens when you write
really garbage code trying to like make
stuff fun live on stream
it's not going to be the normal Pace
that I write stuff is like way slower
than this which would be less
fun so I go a little faster on streamer
I try
to okay invalid
PID so now we have negative
1 which is weird because we have the
grid
tile saying that the uh the grid is not
negative
one so this pit should not be negative
one as far as I can
tell this is one of the very obnoxious
things about having like separate
representations is you don't have like a
single known good source of
Truth um
okay
well I guess I've got to figure that out
now
so you put it on the pit map here but
when you spawn these things
right did they not go on the
grid I'm not seeing them on the grid
this is very
weird speed and quality usually does
help to get an MVP quicker if you build
publicly yeah I want this to at least be
something cool to look
at um the nice thing with snake was like
while I was building snake I just leave
an instance up of it running so like you
could watch the really cool thing you
know while I'm building
stuff the snake project was like a
really nice thing because it was just
that was such a small scale easy project
by
comparison um you know it took this took
a week right including like training
agents and making it super fast and
everything and this GIF is down sampled
it really doesn't do it
well you I did put pids on the map um
and then when I do move
to I'm always setting
PID whenever I'm setting the grid and
I'm always remembering to
oh is this
bad into of player
doy know this is this would be different
so it's you're always setting the new
position on the
grid to be the PID map so if there's
something if there's an agent on the
grid it should have a
PID uh maybe if uh if you like kill one
of the agents it screws up or
something no because if you kill the
agent it just calls
respawn and when you respawn the pit it
moves the agent and when you move the
agent it cleans up the
PID so I'm trying to see where what
other sources of
desync there could possibly be uh
frankly probably the easiest thing to do
is just going to be
to look at these two maps
right I can like just look at the PID
map and look at the
grid let's see yeah so I can do just
like numpy
where grid uh equal
equal I do
agent what's
the agent one
right but what did I make the value for
agent one
weird feel scon makes it easy to follow
to streamer even if you join Midway with
C++ and rust and other low Lang B unless
you've been following for the bit you'd
be pretty lost yeah scon is just really
nice
um I the thing is I like systems and I
like lowl code I do what I don't like is
I don't like the baggage that comes with
it
I don't
like really shitty error messages with
no checking because you haven't done any
like you just have no runtime checks to
make it fast I don't like the syntax
overhead that comes with like
nonperformance critical pieces of code
still having to be strongly
typed um and I really don't like having
to do a big chunky pbind layer cuz you
know your R libraries are pretty much
always in Python so I don't like having
to have a big chunky pbind layer in the
middle so scon cuts out the pbind layer
not required whatsoever it allows you to
Dev really fast because you can have
non-performance critical things in
Python and you can mirror the memory
back and forth and it allows you to do
Native c-speed engineering you have
access to the entire C standard library
and if you want at the C++ standard
Library as
well so uh and you have just cleaner tax
for it there a few rough edges but it's
a really really nice and
underappreciated
tool definitely
that okay so this is telling me that for
some reason uh grid
is the agents aren't on the
grid I think we saw that at the start
though didn't we
what if I Advance One
Step oh if I Advance one step we get
invalid
two maybe there's something that could
be other than zero or
two oh
well it could be a tower
duh Tower equals three or four then you
do this health draw this health bar up
here and then you do I think I can just
unindent this
right asset
Maps Source
wck
Okay cool so this now works um we just
need to have this be an integer
according to this
so yeah because this TS times tile uh TS
Times health bar is just going to
be this needs to be cast to an
INT
and
whoops well that's something we have
very green puffer fish
you like Green
puffer and oh look uh so the health bar
works it's just being drawn uh over the
entire puffer fish so let's fix
that so this is X x chord is
fine uh this is the y coordinate which
is I think row going down maybe so I
times tile size minus
eight eight or
something and then
the uh x coordinate is fine the y
coordinate should be like
four puffer with health
bar look at the puffers with the health
bars
we've got the puffer with the health bar
you can see if I just touch the tower
real
quick it'll attack
right so now we've got a little uh we've
got our little MOA type
thing movement could feel a little bit
smoother you know we'll adjust stuff uh
we'll adjust like speeds and stuff but
so far so good
s and uh I like to tweet something every
couple hours while I'm live just so um
you know it gets a little bit more
engagement helps me
out see if there have been any like cool
comments on stuff as
well very nice though streams work
well yeah um the one thing I really like
about this is just like I'm pretty much
doing my normal work maybe with a couple
small modifications and just streaming
it and uh you know puffer is a new thing
uh My Hope longer term is that companies
will start using it and that they'll
want support contracts or extras or
stuff like that things that will allow
me to grow grow puffer even though
everything's free and open source um and
if I just keep streaming stuff like this
and uh people watch it and you know
different people see and start using
puffer I get to spend my time on dev
instead of on dumb business stuff uh and
that's way more fun and that's way more
productive so that's the way I look at
all this stuff and I have a lot of fun
doing it so it's all good
um maybe we should start to make this
feel smoother to
play I mean there are a lot of ways we
could make this potentially way smoother
to play
that's going to require animation
smoothing though
um so I think we'll we'll wait a little
bit longer on animation smoothing let's
add a couple more things first so these
things have health now um it would be
nice if we could get them
to like click on stuff to attack it
maybe that would be cool
right well I don't even know if the
players are attacking each other right
now it doesn't look like they are
attacking each other so maybe I should
fix that first and then I'll make sure
that the uh we can click on the agents
to attack so you'll have like the MOBA
style control and uh for humans we'll
give you the mouse control and then
obviously the RL agents aren't using a
mouse but it'll be very
similar even though I don't understand
most of it is pretty CH Vibes in here I
got my own project that I'm working on
as a watch yeah that's the idea I mean
this is just like chill
Dev are you going to tackle creep
mechanics today oh yeah I don't know
about that the creep mechanics are going
to be the really hard thing I want to
get the um I want to get a lot of the
core stuff down first right like I want
to have a decent feeling character
controller you know so that they can go
around they can fight each other they
can fight Towers uh stuff like that and
then from there then we'll look at like
creep mechanics and stuff but I want to
get the base of it first um because the
creep mechanics are going to add like
400 lines of stuff I think to the code
base uh I think
probably probably the AI for the creeps
is going to be like 400
um that's going to take a little bit of
thinking so I want to like get
everything good and clean it up and then
add the Creeps in as the next the next
thing uh all the stuff I'm doing now is
going to help with that though because
we're getting the data structures into a
better place that'll make that easier so
okay so the next thing that we want to
do
is write the attacks let's fix up the
attacks with the new attack system
work so the target pit is
always it's always negative one
right let's comment these just to make
sure that we're not getting any
attacks and we'll uncommit the attacks
the Hits and The Kills
computed observation we need to get rid
of all the other garbage prints as
well like these were just test
prints see which of these do we actually
need
Tower
attack need this one
have I thought I saw killed in here
somewhere didn't
I
at okay but is this
the no attacking should
is huh we have all these attacks and no
hits that's weird
right let's mute the tower Prince as
well
because there's too much
yeah so it's it's always just
attacking
um so it's getting a Target pit it's
probably getting
itself is what I'd imagine it's probably
like zero is probably itself and it's
not seeing the other agents around it
would be my
guess let me see if that makes
sense Target
getting a Target but the team is the
same as the own team so yeah I'd imagine
that this is probably something in
compute
observations let's
see
so set idx to zero we Loop over this
range
is oh wait this pit is this pit should
be
fine get player PID and
idx Target ob. PID is equal to
PID I do set the team
H I am still suspicious though of
this this
buffer it makes sense to be suspicious
of this
that I am just not
passing reasonable actions in
attack actions discreete agent idx 2
this should be correct this is where I
would expect the attack to
be I can
print let's do
data okay so this is giving me what I
would consider reasonable data right
it's saying
that you're getting all sorts of
different indices that are
attacking and it's
attacking various different
teams and various different
pids that are not the same as its own
PID which is
weird
dis oh well this is not
assigned so that's just garbage data
that's
fine let's just get a reasonable uh a
reasonable print on like the team so f
agent agent
idx
attacking Target
right and we'll see if the teams look
reasonable
okay so we have lots of
different uh so this is exactly what I
was expecting here
right it's always attacking itself
which
is quite
odd let's see um Target
PID we've got player is get player of
agent
idx and the
target to Target
PID
wait get player
OB agent idx comma
attack is the target
agent idx comma Tech
so
get get player
OB self. player OB of
PID and index which is what we
want so why is this always the same as
the
agent that we are currently getting
somewhere no I don't reassign player
accidentally anywhere in
here player is going to be get agent idx
and then I get
the the
target wait this is compute
observation and we get the player
index set all the pids to negative 1
and pit is equal
to hi map at row and
column get the
player we assign the target observation
to get this player
wa get
player
OB
yes and then we assign the
is not equal to negative 1 it's always
the same as my own
pit I don't know
this is why this like indirect pit
manipulation stuff is so
annoying um I guess I should just start
putting some prints in computer
observations um let's do
PID let's see if we can see agent C's
PID like this
let's see if that code ever
triggers you should definitely be able
to see each
other okay they they all see each other
right this is not the issue
this is going to return you a player
Star right it didn't mess up
reference yeah and this is valid because
I'm setting all of these
I should just be able to print like uh
self.
get uh. health maybe let's just make
sure it's updating
correctly yeah so it is actually
correctly
updating it looks to me like
this compute observation should be
fine uh get player
OB oh
wait this is
it this is wrong right
here
it's agent idx
you want to get the observation of the
current
player it's the observation by the
current player of the target that's
why let's see if this fixes it
perfect now they're attacking each other
you can
see very
nice well I didn't show it on the screen
I'll show that in a second let me just
get rid of these prints and I'll show it
see now they're
fighting and whenever they come into
view of each other they can choose to
they can essentially choose to click on
each other whenever they're in view of
each
other and this is the puffer that I'm
controlling right so I can move this
puffer around the map this is my tower
so it's fine I if I move to the enemy
Tower not so
fine puffer MOBA
very nice um now what we can do is we
can make it so that I can click I guess
I can click on individual agents um one
shouldn't be too
hard so we have the mouse position code
here
and uh I want to get mouse click
position
click you call this am MOA and yet you
haven't been verbally assaulted yet
huh ever played
RuneScape the league and DOTA
communities are the friendliest people
you'll ever meet after
that I come from
MMOs what's the big hey I'm trying to
follow along here and there what has
been the biggest limiting variable in
your work hold on one second I dropped a
chocolate
chip that's not
good that's it okay what's been the
biggest limiting variable in your work
finacing academic papers dead inside
projects data
animations will POA be the answer to all
your prayers for
RL so I mean there have been several
um I'd say that there's a huge amount of
friction between what the accademic Comm
Community considers to be like good
publishable
work and what is actually important for
RL to make
progress there's just a lot of
pedantic
gatekeeping and it really made it very
hard during my PhD to do the type of
work that I wanted and to publish the
type of work that I wanted I mean I got
to the point where basically I could
consistently get papers published if I
wrote what I considered to be a bad
paper emphasizing all the points that I
didn't think were important um and if I
wrote like the good paper I wanted to
write it wouldn't get
accepted
so being out of Academia now I'm no
longer in Academia right that's no
longer an obstacle it's an obstacle to
promoting my work because it means it's
harder to promote it to that community
but um the dev speed has just gone up so
fast like what puffer lib has done in
the last two months I would have not
expected to be remotely possible just
like a year ago and we are rapidly
getting to the point where RL is going
to be a different field in a few months
actually if you look at what puffer lib
is is now if you're actually using
puffer lib for Stuff RL is a different
game than it was two months ago
completely different game um and it's
just going to keep ramping up from here
because this is what now what I'm doing
full-time and I have I basically have no
other objectives that are impeding me
from just making RL work that's just
what I'm doing is making RL
work let me show you the um the puffer
result from
today this
morning I posted this on Twitter so this
is is one of the environments I wrote it
transs at a million steps per second I
ran overnight over 100 experiments on it
uh with carbs hyper pram sweep all
automated and it's just like decimated
all of the best things that I could come
up with overnight completely
automatically this is the type of thing
that happens when you combine good
infrastructure with ultra high
performance
engineering um and it's just going to be
more and more of this you know right now
it's a million steps per second for this
environment soon it'll be a million
steps per second on like a full mobile
and on other environments I'm
developing how to reform the academic
Community you can't I tried for years
you can't
um it doesn't work you just you have to
build the tools outside of Academia and
they'll gladly use all your tools you
know they'll gladly use all your stuff
um but you really just have to wait for
like the new generation of PhD students
who use your stuff for years um to like
move into the positions you know move
into those professorship and Industry
positions because at the moment it's
it's actually impossible to get stuff
done
um I uh I'm not going at least at the
moment I have no plans to go to RL comp
this year because my puffer paper which
you know that's the result of well over
a thousand hours of work and I think my
best work uh got rejected with one
review by a language model review was
written by a language model that made
some stuff about my paper and then one
like kind of rambly senior review that
didn't really make any sense and uh you
know no appeal no nothing it's insane
like the state of Academia is just
pathetic and you know there's no point
in me trying to reform it I'm just like
I've tried very hard I've already spent
during my PhD I spent several hundred
hours maybe thousand hours you know
fighting this trying to do it trying
everything I could possibly think of I
Ran competitions I ran like three
different competitions they took me
thousands of hours to run there was
great personal expense involved in that
there was great financial expense um you
know there was a lot of coordination
that was needed it took like open source
people I tried doing that I tried
organizing a workshop that that didn't
go through because you know freaking
academic Community I tried uh you know
I've tried like organizing local stuff
um I've talked to like many people at
these places um I've like I put together
an open letter that kind of went through
as well
um and like I got I got one result I
guess out of this but it's just so hard
and so much time to do this I'll show
you one thing I'm really proud of that I
that I did get to happen so I I put this
open to letter letter together
NPS I it really just pisses me off even
talking about it it's just like it's so
sad like I wrote this like super rambly
post like hey RL infrastructure sucks
and it's our fault or something like
that and it really is like this is just
self it's this is own goal this whole
thing is just own
goal um okay so right here we have uh
this track this is the nurs data sets
and benchmarks track so full paper track
uh welcomes all work on Yad yada and
open source libraries and tools that
enable or accelerate RL uh ml research
and then it's actually it's stated twice
um it's it's also up here in the
Preamble so uh this was the result of my
my open letters they directly added this
language into the call so hopefully it's
slightly easier to get these types of
papers accepted under this um I mean but
this is really just like it's still so
easy for entrenched reviewers to just
blatantly ignore the instructions so
really you can't do anything uh
unfortunately and yeah literally
reviewer number two is now a language
model my most recent one it like the
review was it made up four different
typos that were not in my paper and then
biased the rest of the review process
and there's still no appeal for
that it's just
pathetic complete own goal as well like
this is our fault
um but I'm out of it now I'm no longer
trying to change Academia from Academia
I'm just going to build good tools
I'll write some blog posts and stuff not
doing the paper game
anymore Mouse X Mouse y I have to
convert this to a tile position I
believe so this is just going to be
this is R Min plus no yeah rmen and then
this is no this is C this is
y so now we can do
Target PID is going to be pids of mouse
Y and mouse
X
um we can do if the target pit is equal
to is not negative 1 then Target is
going to be agents of Target
pit
and uh now we have to find it in our
observations
zero
range and
OBS
players zero I is equal to Target pit
attch equals I break yeah this is just
some garbage code to try to Target stuff
with the
attacks we'll see if this
works and oh yeah we have to return the
attack don't
we uh where's
only
integers okay I have to make this in one
second let me just turn the AC
down PE amazing work regardless the old
gen will be forced to adapt and adopt
the change or be repl yeah I mean that's
kind of just the idea is just like stop
trying to play a weird status game with
like an entrenched Community start
building good stuff that people want to
use and you
know if people want to keep training
Atari and like with increasingly fancy
math at 500 steps per second that's on
them um we'll just be over here with a
really simple code training at like a
100 times their speed very soon and you
know it's not going to matter
right these Sims are going to be a big
part of it as well because like you need
complex tasks that run fast right you
just really need complex tasks that run
fast we can't be doing research on like
slow simple problems
okay so that emulation dopy looks simple
you can go look at the revision history
of that file over the last like you know
all the different versions of perer that
concept and that implementation alone
was like hundreds of hours of work um
because it didn't always use numpy
structure data types it had like really
customized scon stuff to do the same
thing and like it that went through
several different iterations
um so yeah it's really simple now but
and this is kind of what I pride myself
on right like I work really hard to make
stuff that simple now the problem is
when you submit stuff like that to
Academia they go well that's so simple
it doesn't need to be published right
it's like almost if you made it worse if
you made it more complicated that's
better that one emulation file right
there that one little uh that one little
feature Cuts Like thousands to tens of
thousands of lines of code out of every
reinforcement learning library in
existence like you can just delete all
of your code that is associated with
structure data processing you don't need
it anymore emulation that emulation file
does it and it does it faster and
better so it's pretty nice I'm pretty
happy with that
PID right I just had to I just forgot a
cast that's
all uh
cmen was
this in something like
this
yeah okay
so here's the puffer
MMO can I click the puffers oh wait you
have to be able to click the puffers to
to hit the
puffers
ah oh wait I did click the I clicked it
that's why it crashed okay so you need
to
do okay you have to pass it OBS players
cool
oops it's hard to click stuff now cuz
everything's moving super fast right but
like I just want to see if it
works okay
whoops
puffer cannot
compare structured or void to non-void
arrays
here oh okay you literally just have to
hover their Mouse over them uh
PID okay so you just have to hover the
mouse over them right now you don't
actually have to click them that should
make it
easier can we
delete oh
we're hitting it aren't we yeah we're
hitting it right are we hitting it yeah
we're we're totally hitting
it it's really hard to track it it's
really hard to track it I'm really bad
at
tracking yeah yeah we got him okay so I
think this works I think you actually
can hit stuff obviously the UI like the
ux is really Jank yeah that's totally us
hitting it uh the ux is really Jank
but I think we have it um
cool
so that is the basic attack structure of
uh the basic basic basic element the
attack structure of am MOA
um got a lot more to do from here
there's like the towers the towers need
to be attackable um the movement needs
to make actual sense the render needs to
make actual sense so so much to do uh
let's think what I want to do next I
think I want to commit all this first of
all cmoa X
mooba
and is this
it buffer
chars and we going to add this test and
the C test just so I have them
I'm refresh the experiment as well here
to see if it's done anything while I've
been
waiting so it goes from 112 experiments
up to 131 experiments and we've got a
couple of them that are like
close
here uh I'd like to see it run longer
experiments but it just hasn't found a
reason to yet these very cool
though
cool
um I'm going to use the restroom real
quick and when I come back I'm going to
think about what we're going to add next
to the uh the Moa I think I think it's
probably going to
be the ability to attack and Destroy
Towers something like that now there's a
lot of code cleanup that has to be done
but let's try to get like some of the
basics with the tower Tower system done
first I think we'll add like health bars
to towers and uh we'll make them
attackable and stuff like that so I'll
be right
Okay
so we've got some fun stuff to do
here let's add some health bars to the
uh the
towers
probably need to draw a health bar
function right
okay we do health over Max
Health
uh size
whatever and then we will do
draw a health
bar something like this
maybe make sure I didn't break anything
and we'll add the health bar for Towers
oh obviously I did break something I
need to add Max
they that's very
obnoxious I think we're going to have to
change either we're going to have to
change the pit system to be
pointers or we're going to have to do
something with
it we'll figure that out
players yeah let's let's add um pids for
the
towers that'll be a good
idea and then let's add the max health
and stuff we're going to do
Max
Health
oops what the heck is
happening
yeah Max
health and where do I said
Health
XL who has good RL cont content that you
learned the most from on
YouTube
um I don't think I did my RL from
frankly
um because the thing is I when I started
reinforcement learning it was like 2018
there really wasn't much out there um
Kathy has a couple old blog posts that
are nice if you're looking to learn
stuff I would recommend carpath has some
really old blog posts Costa has some
really really good blog posts um and
then there's like the old spinning up
stuff from open AI it's kind of dated
and it has more math than you need but
really it's just like um you know do the
little tiny bit of math to understand
the basics of the algorithms and then
grab clean RL and start hacking on stuff
um clean RL or puffer lib has like a
souped up version of clean RL as well
though maybe base cleaner all will be
simpler just for very very simple
starting stuff um yeah I didn't like
there's not a ton of stuff on YouTube
for like educational RL stuff that I
think is is super
technically my stuff isn't intended to
be educational it just happens to be
educational because of the way I build
stuff and because I like answer
questions um this is really more of like
watch Cutting Edge RL progress happen
live um because that's what this is uh
the types of Sims I'm building here have
never been built before at least not
been built and made widely available um
they've never been built in this way a
way this simple the infrastructure in
puffer lib has never been built before
so like this is all basically new
territory for RL and the field is very
rapidly changing in a matter of months
so that's kind of the idea behind
this plus it's fun it's fun to stream
this
stuff a lot of the math in RL is like
super overhyped it's not that hard um
like for instance did you know that the
main algorithm po it has this really
fancy loss function but for like the
most common use case all the terms
cancel out and it it like reduces to
something way
simpler stuff like that
hard code some
Towers it's not even a telescoping
series it's way simpler than that it's
literally like Po the point of PO is
that like you can train using stale data
old data and it not blow up the learning
process but the thing is if your
simulator is fast there's no need to
train with stale data you always have
fresh data right so like half of the
point of Po just goes out the window and
it's just called pop because like Po is
the algorithm that has the specific
boltons like bolted on stuff that people
generally use like the main thing that
PO does is not even super critical um
yeah it's pretty funny
wait is there a blog post for something
what you're referencing with
po um it's something that I noticed a
long time ago and of course Costa has a
paper on it because you know Costa does
Costa is awesome
um so like Costa po
special okay this is the awesome blog
post uh on PO itself and then I there's
some archive paper on it but
like like
really the concept is very simple so
there's this I think I can even just
prove it in the math right here so not
this not this is see
okay so I guess this is technically it
there's this KL term here between the
old weights this is Pi Pi Theta old this
just says this is a Divergent so how
different is the old policy from the new
policy right
and yeah this is like a version of it so
this is the KL so you have uh policy old
uh a policy and policy old so the old
weights uh on the bottom and the new
weights on the top but the thing is the
first time you take a step so the first
step that you take with
po po uh this the network hasn't been
updated yet so the policy is the old
policy so this term is just
one um so this whole thing just cancels
out uh and then this KL term cancels out
as well because the Divergence between
something in the exact same thing is
there there's no Divergence there um so
like this whole thing just cancels out
if you're essentially just taking one
step per batch of fresh data that you
get now in practice sometimes you need
mini batches and there are like other
things that can happen but in principle
like this doesn't really do anything if
you have fresh data
constantly that's enough math for today
my head hurts math is hard
bad since I see a couple new folks in
here um if you haven't started puffer
lib the repository please go ahead and
do that it uh it helps me out a lot so
I'll open source Dev puffer lib
repository right
here including the project I'm working
now on now it's all open source in
really obnoxious how this works I can do
um I
get
DF Tower get Tower
Min self.
here think I just have to add the towers
to the pit map right
if I do yeah so let's just do like so I
add to the Tower and then I do self. PID
map tower. y Tower dox not equal to
negative 1 it's equal to I plus s.
AG right
okay so the towers
attack players and then the agents can
attack this is awkward because this is
typed
here let's do Tower
star no actually we already have a tower
we can just reuse
so if we have less than numb agents then
we just use
this
else Tower is going to be get
Tower so we're attacking a tower say if
tower. team is not equal to the player.
team then we
do tower. Health minus equal 1
and if it's less than
zero self.
Grid it's going to be empty map is
negative
one I don't know maybe something like
this will do it
we are not going to be able to see the
health bars yet so let's let's fix that
let's add some health bars to these
towers
power need the tower struck as well now
I'm just blowing up I mean we're going
to have to do a big refactor at some
point because of this code is a mess
right right after agents
So Soft do
Towers so and we do
towers and we
do draw a health
bar I think
wrong uh numb agents is
not provided so it's we're just going to
do players. shape
there is it
agents
attacking okay so we actually have it
oops get players now
okay LF pit is less than num
agents then we do all this
right
else we get the
tower and that's uh this is fine right
tower
PID
to what does it have no it has
team health max Health
damage probably have PID right
fine get Tower PID minus num agents then
it gets PID it gets Target OB
dot uh team which is already has it gets
Health it
gets this is fine
like we have
uh Target
PID right so here uh this has to
potentially
be if Target PID
we'll make it slightly nicer right
equals
1 then attack is going to be zero
oops
LF Target pit is less than
agum then you do this you get the Agents
of Target pit right and then uh
or
else you
do uh you still have to do this Loop
right you have to
nest because this nesting lets you pull
this
back Target this is going to be
Towers we'll see if this works
oh yeah we got the tower you see that we
killed the
tower but the thing is the tower doesn't
know it's dead so it's still killing me
but we did Kill the
okay so we just say uh if the tower's
dead then the tower's dead
tower local
variable let's see so I managed to break
it
now or it has my keys backwards or
something something weird just
happened
okay yeah this is fine
weird how that happened that it
eventually doesn't appear to which is
very
odd I also don't understand how um it
like the tower died instantly when I hit
it before right
tower. team Tower health is subtracted
one if the tower health is less than
equal zero then you remove
once and also give them more Health that
might help
okay
um salesman but not a bad salesman
apparently AT&T put one gig uh one gig
in nearby so let's actually actually let
me go check the Wi-Fi speeds here cuz I
could use a little upgrade for the
stream mic still gone yeah mic's still
good yeah I'm supposed to have a gigabit
here so I don't know what the heck this
is yeah that's garbage okay we'll look
at that
cool
um let's take us let's see if we can
figure out what's happened with our
Towers I see is that it's it's taken
down two of the towers it looks
like but
um it's taking down two
I'm going try increasing the tower
Health a little bit will make the tier
ones have
okay and if this works then we have
basic uh defeatable Towers we've got
really basic
characters Graphics are crap a
movement's crap you know the characters
don't even rotate yet but I mean heck I
could put a 3D render for this if I
wanted it's the same under the hood
right
okay I'm not seeing the health bar move
but it seems like the first time I hover
it it doesn't happen like nothing
happens so my guess is that it's uh it
is
actually yeah so right there I hovered
it before and nothing happened and then
it just deleted all at once
so I think that the health is
probably the health Cals are probably
correct and then for some reason the
health bar is
not
working maybe it's because they're both
inss
right
oops yeah let's do like float
right may be like it's because they're
both C integer types under the
Right add a print and see what happened
to Tower HP y That's what I'm doing
okay so all of a sudden it uh it went
from five to zero all of a sudden
right it was at five five and it it
never decreased it just dropped all of a
sudden which is very weird that it would
do that
um I guess I don't need this float check
python should handle in just fine
anyways and know maybe you can see it my
eyes are getting tired uh in a few
minutes I'm going to have to go grab uh
well go make my shake for the
day this is where you do the tower
damage Cal
here get
where's get Tower I mean I would be very
surprised if I'd messed this up right
but where's the function
defined what where did I not to find
this somewhere oh here it is Tower
agents this is correct it' be very weird
for this function to be
wrong oh I think I
know uh did I not
pass no I did pass this correctly I
thought I didn't provide the type on the
tower so maybe it copied
Towers this created the exact same way
that uh players is
created and then we pass out. sea Towers
after creeps right
of thises health bar
worked
um the fact that this is
drawing it in the first
place I'm going to just do this for a
second I just want to see if it's
actually picking up the
Health Okay so so right here it says I
have very low Health right
because and now this one has more health
because it's a stronger Tower
right so it means that the data actually
has to be
correctly added in
here it's weird though that you never
kill this
Tower I would expect you to eventually
be able to kill it
you
don't you only kill oh wait you do kill
it so it takes a while but you do kill
it uh and then this one actually has the
wrong amount of
HP we can see that this is not added
correctly so I'm setting the HP from the
cide so the fact that I can see it means
that the data is correctly synced
between Python and C so we don't need to
worry about that
then oh am I drawing the wrong health
bars above each of them that could be a
thing right I could be drawing the wrong
health bar like it could be decreasing
the health bar of a different
one let me say PID minus agent. shape
let's print the
PID let's see what this Tower's pit
20 let's see if there's a ah this one
right here so this one got
killed you see so it is just updating
the wrong health bar
okay
so this is
ji this is
fine PID 20
towers it's I plus numb
agents we get the
tower turn PID minus numb
agents maybe I'm decrementing the health
of the wrong Tower let's
see
so we get PID
map oh wait this is the player killing
the Tower or the tower killing the
player now the player Tower ah right
here this wrapped around somehow and I
got negative
so now we have the
puffer and can it attack the tower
help so get Target pit is going to be
the
target.
PID
wait this is Tower
PID Tower PID
right get tower Tower
PID
no get Tower
of what did I have it as before Target P
minus num
agents where did I get Target PID from
get player
I messed up some indexing here somewhere
I just don't see where I'm not seeing it
so I even though this is get player OBS
they should have the correct pit in it
so is this not just Target
pit just add a print in see what it's
see what PID we're
go
20 it's right there
wait where do I set the
pids oh I don't set the
pids
right I set the pit map but I didn't set
the tower pit there we go Sprint
bizarre I thought that I fixed it with
that oh wait did maybe wait wait wait no
no no hold
on get
Tower yeah you can't do get Tower of I
right it's got to be I Plus
I'm
agents H I'm going to have to refactor
this very very heavily probably off
stream because it'll be boring but um
yeah this
like hopefully we just get it working
for
now and make it
work ah there we go look we uh we I saw
the tower take damage so here we're
going to damage this Tower here it's got
a little bit of Chip damage right we can
see it okay we're going to
attack you can actually see the chip
damage that the tower takes
right
boom then this we can go get ready to to
attack this Tower except this is our
Tower so we can't attack it obviously we
got in range of the other one very nice
so we have a very very basic like bare
bare minimum MOA type thing going on
here
um towers of Stars players are
puffers if I hover over these puffers
here by the way they get hit so like you
actually can fight stuff it's just very
awkward because like they're very
spammy they're very very spammy and the
movement's too
fast but that'll be easy to solve um
we'll just like reduce the movement
speed or whatever and you don't have to
render the you don't have to render the
puffer on a tile that's very easy to
I think we don't even have to recompile
for that we can just do agent speed is
going to be 0.5
right and
then
here it actually might just be done for
us
because yeah main R main
C I think it just works for us right
so if I'm I'm holding the up key and
nothing is
happening clearly the speed is applying
to the other puffers not to me though so
let's see what's wrong
when you think about all the things
you're going to
solve you have like a project management
thing that helps you visualize goals or
you just go through the motions and like
oh I'll fix that
next
um honestly the only thing that's really
important is getting the lowlevel data
structures
right like everything else
is so this is more lines of code than it
should be by like almost double right
now because I've just been lazy with the
way I've been writing it but the way I
think about things is I as long as I
keep a project under like 2,000 lines I
can kind of just load the whole project
into my head at once
right
um so I basically I just solve the next
thing because it doesn't need more
structure the cost of adding the
structure outweighs the benefit
doesn't mean that I'm going to keep the
code looking like this it's going to
look way nicer and be way more concise
but um I I just keep it short enough
that it's relatively easier to just
solve the next thing solve the next
know did you know that if you just solve
the next thing thing and you keep
solving the next thing eventually all
the things are solved
you ain't wrong when you're
right
yeah I don't know I've never really
found structure to be useful
like the vast ma majority of the time
like when you try to create structure
and you try to like you know put things
into boxes you're just wrong like you
come up with stupid boxes you come up
with stupid structure it's better to
just solve the thing and not do the
structure and try to like compactify and
clean stuff up along the way like that's
pretty much
it right where's movement and why is it
only happening in discreet
chunks discretize
why I actually don't see why this
doesn't
work like
looks like it should
work doesn't move you on the grid right
but
then this destination here is continuous
unless I messed that up
somehow player.
y plus agent speed times velocity y
the kicker should be that
um for whatever reason the scripted
agents or the the neural agents work and
mine
doesn't let's see why that would
I assume that the fact that the YouTube
counter keeps going to zero and then
going back to two means that like
YouTube C doesn't count T tabbed out
users so
um it just like whenever people Tab out
it goes to zero and then whenever
something happens and they tab in it
goes back to like you know back to two
or whatever that took me a second to
figure out whereas I think that the
twitch one is just Conant I think that
the twitch one counts background or
something and then the X1 just makes
absolutely no sense because it tells you
total views not concurrent viewers
I really don't see anything that would
uh
make this Mak sense let me just play
with it a little
so if I hit this I go left if I just
keep tapping
left and if I keep tapping up do I go
up but if I hold
it and just get stuck is that the
case that's weird
is key
down gives you the
axis either of them are
none the action is
none
print think though I can print my action
out and I think it'll be reasonable
right
I'm going to just hold the up
key yeah so my upkey hold I can
see left key yeah so the I can see the
printouts
here so it's getting reasonable actions
actions it's getting the movement right
where's the move thing
if
discretise actions
discret minus
1.0 which is correct I
speed if uh agent let's just
print
this let's just check the velocities
like this
okay oops
so agent is moving
to is as soon as I hold down a key it
locks it and I have reasonable
velocities
but it blocks me after a
second so it's moving to a
position with what looks like a
reasonable
to ah right here
this needs to be
here you
always
no if it's
so if the grid is not
empty
and
PID is not equal to PID so you have to
check both
that uh you you're allowed to move into
your same cell
yeah so if you would move into a cell
that's occupied you're not allowed to do
that but you have to be able to check
against your own your own
issue also I screwed up this
indent this indent needs to be here
and now we have these
puffers
uh now nobody can move
oh I did I delete the wait hold
on I deleted the
original right
yeah
okay so I'm moving at half speed but
it's not rendering the puffer smoothly
enough you can see it's only moving it
it's rendering it in chunks of tiles so
let's fix that
where's the
move
H this is fine
C this is
correct um but then
this this is not necessarily correct
no which got to be minus the Min
right minus r
it okay it actually works but the health
bars are wrong let's fix the health bars
I'm actually surprised how wrong the
health bars
are or maybe it's not how wrong the
health bars are maybe it's how wrong the
puffers
are we should probably get like an X Y
thing right so like let's go here
so we'll
okay let's do
entity is equal to agents of
PID else entity is equal the towers of
this okay and we'll get rid of this this
code here and we'll just
doy and what we're going to do is XX is
going to
be
minus r min
maybe that
works and we'll
do
minus oh this is C this is
rmen right and we'll do draw health bars
this will be XX this will be y
y and then this will be D
direct like
this let's see how this
works integer
required no
problemo and once this works it'll be a
lot less
choppy uh it's still now it's still
cropping me to
be yeah this is still
cropping let's see
why oh it's I think you need to apply
this int
times tile size yeah you have to do the
multiplication by the tile size yeah and
then do the cast Okay so
draw health bars yeah so what we'll do
is we'll just
do x y and this will just be we don't
need the tile size anymore in this
function this will just
be
X this will be
y uh we do actually need the tile size
that's
so XX y y death
direct
cool this did not the puffer is not
pleased this did not work
um let's see what happened oh because I
forgot to remove this one here
we don't need this tile size
anymore so you can kind of go into
objects but
um you can see that it's
actually it moves by half steps
is it just me or is it
flickering why does it look to me like
it's
flickering it is right it's not it's
like going forward and then jumping back
isn't
if I do it like really slow we should be
able to see the
flicker ah the flicker because the map
is
snapped so we'll fix that
mean
one plus
one we'll just give it like a one tile
buffer I
I think you do I
minus got to be I minus one right I
where do we use
I oh it's just used
here right is this the only spot
technically if I do like DX
here
Dr is going to be
main minus
int
okay so you take off this portion
here and now you can
do I was it I plus - one plus
Dr
D yeah this is Dr
see okay I think I got it backwards
right so let's try minus
smooth oh so I think now that you can
just
right let's see can you just do like
this now
not
nope what did I have it as before this
is J
times tile
size do I just have it backwards isn't
this J and this is
I
yeah okay so this is now
smooth um this is moving with me which
is not good
it's actually kind of gives you
Collision detection for free as
obnoxious
so I think we need to do a little bit of
math on
this I always hate having to do centered
camera I always hate having to do
centered camera
there is technically a camera thing we
could use with rayb I don't know if it's
worth
it I don't think it's that bad to just
do the math
is I don't know how we want to do this
honestly
well I think the camera actually might
help let me go see if I can grab a
camera snippet this will take it a
little bit but then the nice thing with
the camera is we can just draw
everything at its actual correct
position on the board
um and it'll work itself out from that
we don't have to do
everything let me go find the uh let me
go find the thing oh anything on let me
check Twitter real quick because I
haven't checked that in a while
advertising cool
stream's actually doing quite
well uh it's uh
not oh no this is yesterday's stream
isn't it ah
whatever this one's doing
okay let's go look for uh let me go grab
the uh the code off screen one
second and we'll show you the rib camera
system which if I recall it was a little
bit annoying to get set up but uh wasn't
that
it do I have pyr what is
it Ray Li okay so you need pyr for this
which is slightly annoying but not too
bad
because the um this is one of the things
for which the CI is really
obnoxious so then what we do is I think
we just set the camera
camera forget if we have to attach the
camera somehow I don't think so I think
now what we get to do is we just get to
use the actual coordinates for
everything
and we will uh just we'll render so we
don't need Dr don't need
DC we'll keep this Min and Max
thing uh we actually won't need this inj
anymore then either which is very nice
because this was very obnoxious the way
that I wrote this it was quite
stupid
and now it is simp
L this is going to be
y x
right and if we
do uh y
y
x
x GD
YX and then we just draw this
rectangle um this is going to just be
into this is just X time TI size right x
* TI size y * TI size very
simple and just python I think you get
you just get ins back right if I do
like type 3 * 5 just give you an INT
yeah it does give you an in
okay so this should be nice nicely done
this is now y x this will clean up the
code quite a bit for
us uh and then the health bar
I think I can make uh we're going to
reuse this a bunch
right I think I can do t t x it's x x
ts you just do TX Ty Y and easier TX
dy I need
this TX Ty
y TX Ty
y okay
let's see what
happens wish it wouldn't spawn off
screen but we have a spawns on an IT
spawns empty which I mean I'd assume
mean that the camera Target was not
set so we can
do
um
camera Target dox is going to be
equal to main C time tile
size self dot dot see how this
blank uh let me go pull up that other
bit of
code uh you need to be begin mode 2D
right so our ALB has this begin
draw
um and you need to begin the camera and
end the camera
it's dot begin mode
D then you end the draw and then you end
RL end mode
2D uh no other way around they need to
be sandwiched like
okay okay so this is something
right something weird
happened I don't exactly know what this
is maybe we can deduce what happened
here I think you have to add half of the
uh the screen width to this
maybe do I have width and
height yeah
so plus self dot with over two it's
going to be time TI size height and uh
wait what did we specify width and
height this actually does have to be
times tile size
right so this is actually going to
be m
two times tile
size and then I can click this
okay I think this was minus I think that
the suggestion was correct because I
don't see
anything okay so this is actually
correctly centered
now we can see that there's a little bit
of diverging
here but the camera is smooth so it just
means that the math on our objects is
wrong but we can see that the stationary
objects are consistent with the
camera are either of these
centered this health bar looks like it's
centered to me
right yeah this health bar is
centered and then there shouldn't be a
star there which is
weird possibly I flipped some
coordinates
yeah uh well here's the
issue I just typoed Ty
promising okay so now the puffer is uh
the puffer is not moving smoothly but
everything else is moving smoothly so
so this should not be x * tile size
right this should so I should put X time
tile size
here tile size this is y * tile
size but then down
lower I should
do TX equal to
entity
dot int
entity dox time to size so now this
should give you
smooth uh possibly smooth placement of
these oh
yeah let's speed it up so it looks a
little bit better this is just uh a
little bit too
slow oh yeah this is this is great look
at this
so we have smooth movement can I still
hit stuff oh yeah I can still hit stuff
perfect so we have smooth movement we've
got smooth movement in
combat um the puffer does not rotate
towards the direction you're moving so
we'll fix that I'm sure we'll do some
stuff it be nice to have like an
overhead puffer or
this is probably worth putting like a a
little update together
right overhead puffer would go
hard yeah it's kind of weird because
like if you think of the um the way
mobas do their characters I've never
seen like a 2d mooba right like a top
down I could do top down puffer it
wouldn't be that hard I do have the 3D
files for this
thing I mean it's also possible I could
make a 3D client for this I don't know
how I feel about doing that work but
um technically something that could be
done
right but this is like this is pretty
cool like this feels this feels pretty
fluid
uh if you want it to be really
smooth I if you wanted it to be really
smooth what you would do is you would um
decrease the agent speed and up the
frame rate uh but that will make it
substantially harder for learning it
would make it substantially harder for
learning though I think that am MOA is
kind of fundamentally more real
time let me try
something I'm going to do
puffer you
human wait
FPS Target is only
10 we could do like 20 or no let's do 30
o2 okay it's a kind of a jittery puff
puff Jitters a little bit because this
is a highly unoptimized code but uh you
can absolutely like you have like very
smooth circular control
now you
see but this is a little too
jittery a little too fast let me try 20
smooth so technically each of these
squares you have a resolution of four
steps in each of these squares like you
can move it's technically there's a grid
map thing but you you can move a
distance of a quarter of a square every
frame in any direction eight directional
because I have this uh like this oh you
know what I can
do I have a really good idea wait wait I
have a really good idea this is going to
be
cool we're going to make it we're going
to make it real cool okay
it's going to be
fun so I'm going to ignore these key
presses
here and I'm going to
200 and I'm going to clip this to
between negative 1 and
one I'm just I'm just doing things you
know it's no big deal hold on we just we
just uh there's there's just a little
bit of stuff we got to do
okay don't be alarmed we're not we're
not doing anything super cool or
anything like that right
okay so I was totally right because
people every time I say something
interesting somebody will like speak up
in the chat even though that the view
counters are zero so it's totally just
not counting tabbed out people that's
how it is that's cool it's kind of cool
to know that your view numbers are
actually higher than displayed
the one thing that's a little Annoying
is I
think do we need to change stuff a
little bit for
this let me see
got ax and a
y not
broadcast right I needed to
Define is equal to
the attack is going to be a little bit
of an issue we we'll fix it up though
it'll be cool it'll be
fine actions discreet
what where is
this oh this is
continuous
hey buffer
continuous hey buffer where you going
puffer wait do I have to
do
I like Puffer that follows your cursor
as an
environment you know technically if I
wanted to make this 3D I do have the 3D
model of the puffer and it does have one
animation and this would be a really
really great excuse to commission more
puffer fish animations which I love to
do but the thing is they're very
expensive and very time consuming to
have
made I do like them
though dude just upwork it okay that's
what I did for the original puffer right
and it took two artists about 600 bucks
and several hundred messages to get this
puffer the way I want wanted
it is not
easy it's a very high quality
puffer it's very difficult to do
characters like animated characters like
if you have one polygon off slightly
like the whole thing is messed up like I
would I'd have to send back edits like
you know hey there's one polygon off on
the mouth or like you know the fin is
just clipping ever so slightly here or
like the eyes are just like slightly
going to a weird angle that looks off
right stuff like
that for this
reason artist jobs are actually very
safe despite
being plus as annoying as it is to send
100 messages back and forth um they do
actually fix the things that you say
instead of just making more
issues and there the artists are
credited on the puffer page as
wait am I not printing the action
already let's print the action as it
goes in
Mouse oh oh did I already just divide
the
mouse
this pause.
y pause. x
buer follow
me no it
doesn't it's at least moving
now uh
okay
so this says that Mouse
is very reasonable right so this
is Target is
784 which
is here which is a little
awkward but then there's
10,000 oh
yeah duh um I have to do the center of
the screen not the mouse y so this is
just pause y
minus uh self.
height
uh super Maven I love you but your
suggestions are not always
amazing you are very fast though
puffer
Mouse well we don't need this target
anymore right we need
puffer let me
through
puffers it's just a really bad seed okay
well we'll have to look at it from here
so the mouse is 650
Target
is ah it's times T it's TS
times T TS times
right
TS come on so
puffer what would you recommend a good
beginner project be for using clean RL
for the first time um well first of all
like just train some like train like one
of the existing M to see how it works
and set up like wand B and um it depends
what you're focused on like I generally
suggest like trying to make either make
a new en and make RL work on it or get
RL to work on like a simple existing
environment uh nothing as complex as
this thing but look at this you can
actually navigate your
puffer you can navigate the puffer with
your cursor and if you put the cursor
very close the puffer moves a little bit
and if you put the cursor far it
navigates a
intelligence does it still kill
stuff oh yeah it does
sweet I actually yeah I tweeted that
artificial puffer intelligence has been
achieved internally
right that was a good one
intelligence camera made this so yeah
it's so smooth with the camera
right I mean this is kind of like a
basic little
game this is a reasonable speed as well
right little MOBA
we could do click movement click
movement would be harder to
implement
um yeah click movement would be a fair
bit harder to
though but this like navigation feels
really smooth this actually like this
feels really good to play
with if we had a top down Puffer that
like rotated in the direction as
well I don't know why these look so
jumpy well they're constantly modifying
their velocity like faster than I can I
can do it they're just acting randomly
so I guess makes sense that they're
smooth this is why I do this type of
stuff because like this is very
satisfying and I'm going to tell you
it's going to be so much cooler as well
when you have like these smooth moving
puffers and like all of them are moving
and doing something coordinated looking
it's actually going to look really
attack o the puffers are too
strong can't get close to them oh you
know what it is it's that I clipped the
action space yeah yeah yeah so we
actually have to mess with the action
space stuff because I can't hit them
so the funny thing about that is I
actually there is already in open source
mode I just haven't released it yet it's
like it's 90% done I just can't bring
myself to finish the thing because it
requires a bunch of janky experiments
but uh there's going to be something
really cool to share very
soon something that is at least as
complicated as the finished game of this
would be
but yeah it is kind of an open source
Moe in the sense that like hey all these
M are in puffer lib right so like you
may as well even if you're not going to
use all the stuff in puffer lib like you
may as well use puffer lib for for the
environments and that's really all I
care about is like if I have people
using puffer lib for something and like
enjoying it and like you know hanging
out and giving feedback I'm happy I just
want people using my stuff
and of course like you can hard Fork
stuff and vendor it or whatever but it's
it's bad etiquette and like there's not
really much reason to when it's being
actively maintained for free
here right let's fix the AL space real
quick then we'll get it working discret
and continuous maybe a lot of things we
can do so
1 1
0 high is equal to 1 1 and
10 let's see if this does
it actions do not match the action
space and
okay right because you need to have it
clipped it it needs to be low and high
and then you need to clip it I think
is that how it
obnoxious okay
so we have the
Papa we have uh Z
attack oh now it works
what was hitting
me can I hit you why it looks like I can
hit you
right I don't know how you're hitting me
so
okay yeah I can't actually hit all of
them see if you go from the bottom here
you can see like they don't really hit
you as much you can hit the one that's
like right above you I think but you
can't hit the one below you
do you penalize the agents from being
too jittery and is it a good idea these
agents are not trained this is a new
project I started it yesterday so these
uh they are neural Nets we do have
neural Nets running on it but um the
agents are random they're acting
randomly so yeah they're going to Jitter
until uh either I could add a smoothness
penalty to be fair during training might
not be a terrible idea smoothness reward
something like that
um or they might just learn it probably
some sort of smoothness
reward it's a fine
idea uh I would like to know why uh why
the attack is not working the attack
action is not
working Target
equals can I wait can I like hit I
should be able to see the target change
at least right oops
so let's say I go like this right
oops I should be able to see my
target I'm not seeing any Targets
here am I hitting myself what the what
is going on here I think am I hitting
myself or something like
what is there's nothing that can damage
me here
zero Mouse y Mouse
X
let's just print all of
this reward Mouse looping
agents
okay Mouse is at 50 Target is negative
1 Target is
four Target is
if I put my uh my mouse on my the own
puffer fish
right this does not take it from
negative 1 to
zero it should be zero right because I
I'm not negative
one let I have a check against that but
no
I I
don't
um you can get some Targets in here
stuff should be like especially up there
yeah you can get targets
oh wait is this
backwards no
R yeah this is correct
wait what do we have C
Min no C
here plus the X
position I might be off by
one is the mouse off by
one I might have just added like a
little off by one error let me see
Target's Nega
1 no target appears to be negative one
everywhere
H yeah I just realized that yeah I
realized that in like surely audience I
have on a reinforcement learning stream
is not going to point that out but of
course it's the
y I kind of just want to draw a circle
at Mouse X and Y
right uh probably super MAV will do it
raw at Mouse x y
okay let's see
so okay so we can see that the the
circle is
wrong and oh yeah I saw it it just it
hit the puffer when I hit the when I had
the circle over the puffer I saw it hit
zero for a second
one I don't know where there would be an
off by two error
from oh there's not an off by to there's
an off by 0.
circle
what I guess there's not an off by
0.5 hold
on
I think you give it the center position
right
it's plus tile size over two is the
corner plus tile size over
two maybe this does it right if you div
it uh one
one maybe don't drop the pupper in the
Okay so
if you have your cursor on
here is it plus
two man I can't freaking
tell I want to have the cursor be
I mean maybe I need to discretize after
all yeah but it's not plus
two
it's why is the X1 the X1 appears
correct and then the Y is wrong
right I messed that up
somehow look if I'm on this tile
here oh no it's half tile off
it's very
camera I think I could
right so
right and then let's
do mouse X is going to
be into of
the ra maybe this does
it oh
yeah
so this is pretty much spoton right as
soon as you go to the next tile it flips
perfect so and if I put this cursor on
the puffer it does not do
anything uh if I put the cursor
here ah here's where it says the puffer
cursor must be so if I put it on the
puffer
no it's pretty much accurate
right it says that I'm still on this
tile and if I go over one I'm on this
tile so if this is accurate enough can I
kill stuff with
it but I should be able to put my cursor
on stuff right
19 Target is negative 1
7 so you're seeing stuff in
here I mean it's hard to catch them
because they're like you know they're
fiddly
this did I just do damage to it or did I
not I can't tell because the cursor is
like you can't tell what tile the thing
is on
right well the agents can I just can't
so I'll just probably have to implement
some like nearest like some like Grace
bubble or whatever on the cursor like
some click off Grace thing that's
fine good enough for the time being um I
I got to make myself a shake real quick
so I'm going to commit this up I'm going
to go make myself a shake and then I'm
going to be right back and we'll finish
uh some we'll figure out a couple other
fun things to do today with this
and I I'll leave this up running as well
because I may as
okay we are
back um I've decided what the next thing
is going to be I've got a little over an
hour we're going to implement the first
skill in this game
we're going to implement the first
skill oops
ah come on puffers
stop oh no I forgot that it's adding all
these frames to a
buffer okay
okay so we're gonna add the first skill
to the puffer game uh the first skill is
going to be puffer blast it's very
game ready for puffer blast okay um
puffer blast we need to add a two
to
this four
a
skill
zero if
key uh space is
fine a scills equal to
one and we where's the
action right here
skill
do well initially we're just going to
make something
I should make like an attack function
probably I'm going to just need to call
it a few times
there whatever we'll do like this maybe
for now
and uh let's see if we can get this to
work and then if we can get this to
okay does the attack function still work
yes it does that's very nice
nice
skill
attack
Sid
okay now what we do is
Target uh we
do
int r no int
y
int target. y
then we
yeah
int
D
Dy
attack PID
equals PID
is1 no you can just do Pit is equal to
self. PID
Target PID this is Target
PID so we're just going to make a little
simple
we'll do skill attack beant skill
attack beant skill
cast to Bull and then we'll
do uh like this and we'll just say
greater than
0.5 it's greater than 0.5 you use the
skill
for
continuous
and if
skill
else attack
so we'll see if we can strike for
massive
Q I'm having difficulty getting close to
the puffers to even
Health let's do the player max health is
going to be like 100
damage damage
now
damage into
attack then damage is going to be
like lots 30 damage lots of damage
damage and then this one is going to
puffer it's done lots of damage to
me can we do
q
no they do damage very quickly though to
you don't they
let's do um let's make Dr and DC a
little bit bigger so we can just tell a
little
what so like
three four three
four oops we got to
recompile so basically now
um this should just be blasting stuff
boom I can't tell if it's using the uh
the blast thing I suspect it's not
because they're not just like getting
deleted so let's just
see oh I'm holding the wrong key I I
just instinctively held Q instead of the
key that I B
okay oh yeah this is you can see the
damage here right it's
like but they're using puffer strike
back on me that's why I'm taking so much
damage that's so
funny so like yeah you get just
absolutely shredded by this
thing yeah like you can see the like the
big chunk of damage that's the puffer
strike uh does this let
me is my tower out of bounds okay I have
to be careful with the bounds of the map
I haven't solved that yet good to
wait Target
doy
H the skill attack does uh doesn't seem
to work
um -3 to
4 PID
map y + Dy and X+
how did this work
before get player
wrong oh this this is not uh yeah this
is not how it's supposed to work here
this
is yeah okay so I have to refactor stuff
a little
do let's take like these lines back put
these back into the loop right
and we'll do
like what is it
and now instead of attack we can just do
Target PID Target
PID and Target PID now we refactor the
skill to take into account the target
PID um so this is
now was it Target PID
anymore I do need uh Y and X though
right I do need the player OB On Target
pit like
this and then you get Y and X right d y
and DX
okay and then we do attack the target
PID PID Target
PID this is Target PID
damage get this is now do not need this
anymore see death player star
player and then we do the target here
need player star Target does not need to
be this and we need Tower Star
Tower okay so now we have Target
Tower maybe this is enough let's
check even with the this file being
garbage by the way it's only 500
garbage all right let's see do we get uh
any attacks can I attack this
thing ah it's not letting me hit it and
it's very very slowly killing me what
about if I hit space on it nope so I do
not do damage and it very slowly kills
me let's see why that
in
turn we can now unindent this stuff
here you get player
OB and you get the pit from that that
looks is that correct
wait not from attack
right you know this is is correct cuz
this is attack is the index into your
observation you get the target from the
observation you get the pit from the
target observation and then you pass the
target pit like
this so that actually looks correct to
me Target pits less than num
agents all this
player start
Target get player
PID uh did I give it the wrong pit to
begin
with hold
on now agent idx is the right pit isn't
it agent idx is the right
pit weird
weird that it doesn't wait I just saw
the target is
10 so it's getting
okay
so now
we can see the target is
10 it's attacking five attacking three
attacking five attacking
three it's oscillating all over the
place which is very
weird well could be this puffer right
here
that's screwing it
up but um if even if I go like way over
here
right target
10 attacking
five five it looks like it's attacking
five okay um
it's I think it is wor is it does like
the other puffers die when I do this
yeah they actually do die very quickly
it looks
like yeah look at that you can see at
the bottom of the screen so for some
reason the pit is wrong
PID
so get player
OBS and then when you're attacking you
get the
target attacking five attacking five
attacking
five we know that's not the target
pit
because uh five is not the pit of a
tower so that's totally
wrong so of course it's attacking
something different that's not what it
should
be the question is where does five come
attack
if agent idx is
zero we'll do
this darn debugging
okay so raw attack is now
zero raw attack is still zero they can't
see it
right raw attack I just saw
two two on this puffer Maybe
hold
on and then raw attack is
zero or
sense let
see attack is zero and then if I go here
I think if you go above it it's one
right yeah so the reason is that um it's
Computing a window of observations
around the puffer and the puffer is in
the center so if you
start up here this will be zero here but
uh if you're up here it'll be
one yeah that's how that
works um and that's actually fine
because you get the player
OB and then you give it the
PID but then why do you get the wrong
pit out of
this why do you get do you get your own
pit
maybe five could be my own pit right no
no five is not my own pit CU my own pit
is zero your puffer
zero ah
this this whole pit data structure is
really obnoxious as
wait well this one is
wrong but this one looks like it should
be right
Target PID less than numb agents you get
the target as Target
PID attacking Target
pit Target pit five
it's very weird that I'm actually seeing
attack numbers in
here there should absolutely not be any
here
attack right
attacking yeah this is only printed for
pit
zero so
oh well this one is because let's fix
this one this one needs to be get player
not get player
OB um
and you know this is not even going to
necessarily work because the target
pit
wait no it is get player OB
right you get the player op from the
from here in order to get this target
object and then you get this PID
map over which you can check coordinates
I
so we'll do
um
print skill
attacking
pit and we'll go just use this
from I don't know wherever right
zero come on I want to have this skill
thing done today the very least
okay so we have
reward and if I go up
here you can see
the
oops 71
one okay this is very
odd if
I just doesn't attack does not apply
attacks
weird I just can't figure out what the
heck this is I'm like what would
actually tell me for sure
um what would tell me for sure what's
going
wrong there's really not much cuz like
the stupid state based
like this PID matching thing is so
obnoxious I had the attack working
before as well so I don't know what
happened like what did I do with it to
mess it up actually that's a better
question let's just go check the last
commit and see what I changed that
probably I should have done that a while
ago right
perfect time to remind you to start the
puffer helps me out a whole
so Target is get player
OB PID attack
Target pit is target.
PID we on attack here agent idx Target
PID agent idx Target
pit
then we
have player is get player of my own
pit Target
is Target PID right get player Target
PID the track
Target
PID
yeah now where do I get the
Target right
here Target is get
player Target
ped and then this is the same right
target team Target
Health SP Target pit
is it something with the way I like
changed passing observations or
something
weird I mean passing actions to this
thing cuz I'm not seeing
it I mean this is
so technically I did this
above I put this up here I think right
would make a
difference oh does it no no it doesn't
doesn't make a
difference get player
OBS PID and
attack where's attack
yeah so we have
attack which is
from in agent can Yep this is the exact
same
players get player agent idx and I pass
agent
idx it pass the target
PID to
this play get
pit player star Target
Tower Target get player
this this really looked correct I don't
know what the heck is wrong with
it uh and there way there's way too much
printing going on as well let me let me
see if I can just like thin down the
print so I can maybe tell what's going
on so like print this is everything's
getting printed is too much too
much
yeah and
okay so I should be able to see the PID
that I'm attacking whoops from
here now I'm on target four
right why is the target changing
there's absolutely no reason the target
should be
wait
oh my
God damn
it right
here code
hygiene freaking code
hygiene what I get for hacking stuff
fast for stream it's like you go fast
and then you go slow because says you
wrote crap
code so we'll see I might just start by
cleaning this up for a few hours
tomorrow okay beautiful so now we have
the target
correct does it attack this
thing yep it attacks this
thing um we can very very slowly attack
it oops got to get ourselves killed here
or we can very very quickly
well they're the thing is they're using
the skill back on us so
um and we're getting out of bounds
here let's
see skill
ID should tell me the Target ID
shouldn't it Target is
this is not what we need it's just get
player Target
work and we'll add uh we'll add one more
much easier to code skill than
right out of bounds
still oh right because the uh the target
pit is a tower in this
case
o Target pit is a
tower for
so first of all
if Target
PID
player
okay we get y we get
X try
this garbage code
it's very difficult to actually hit the
thing isn't it
let me
see okay so I can hit it but I can't use
the
spell
heck get
Tower this stupid auto correct is just
bad sometimes super Maven needs to
update the
model to be god tier just send me good
code model that does a good
thing uh I should be dead right yeah
okay it's it's basically
dead okay we deleted that thing because
we have the burst on
it can we uh burst anything
boom yeah we can burst stuff I can tell
we're we're doing damage here can we hit
uh one of these towers
like boom Oh yeah I just saw it we
deleted both of them at once okay
great second puffer
skill C
def
skill heal
heal okay and we need um need a trigger
for this right
is going to
be pack
skill skill
attack skill
heill skill
attack L this should be L
Shi one
okay and then we will add into the
attacks we'll
add just watched your thesis defense
came here to tune in thank you very much
yeah a lot of people have uh come from
there so uh this is now me graduated
live trying to fix the total mess that
RL is in by doing ultra high perf Dev uh
if you just saw the stream the thing
that we did a couple weeks ago I built
this this is a 4096 snake environment
that runs at 14 million uh steps per
second on one CPU core and trains it a
million steps per second on one GPU so
it's going to be a lot of ultra high
performance Sim it's a lot of like cool
RL infrastructure
Dev hold on let me find another cool
thing got to sell the new
viewers so here's uh a sweep that we
have running right now with uh very
fancy hyper parameter tuning this has
run probably like 80 billion steps worth
of training by now overnight over the
last day uh so yeah a lot of just fixing
RL Dev live and if you like what you see
stick around and of course uh feed the
puff or a star helps me out a
bunch that's the pitch
currently building a little MOA for uh
reinforcement learning Dev reinforcement
learning
let's go
here right
and let's see if this renders
now no key lshift okay so it's a
different key code
shift okay so there's no uh
key shift
apparently I mean I can just do q and E
right or q and
W this can be Q
can be
w could not broadcast so I have to
update this space I
think action
space space
five okay now we get to play the puffer
Mo a little bit so oh there we go that's
the full heal spell we can burst this
yep we can just completely wreck this if
we press uh w we full
heal we can delete that we can
heal uh what if we just press like Q
Once on This
oh we died because we were not fast
enough
okay solid
enough basics of a puffer mooba coming
along got our
Towers we can heal we can hit this Tower
yeah this is like reasonable
I mean this is kind of already to the
point where um if I were to like tune
this a little bit we could probably even
get some cool behaviors out of it of
course it's still incredibly incredibly
basic but um not bad for two days worth
of Dev I'd
say the movement feels really good like
the fact that I have uh the Excel like
so you do little close movements like
this and then you can go fast that feels
really good
and of course we can do like classes and
stuff maybe so like I could make the the
heel be like an AOE that only one of
them has or something and we'll add cool
Downs there's lots of cool stuff we can
do from here uh codes a mess definitely
needs to be cleaned up
here I don't want to start on the
minions until much
later I want to have like a relatively
complete game without obviously the
minions being a major major thing just
cuz they're going to be a pain to
implement
tricky I mean we don't have like the
armor Health like all like the uh the
main stuff that would make them truly
distinct we also don't have cooldowns on
stuff or a UI we're missing all of
that um let me think if there's anything
cool I can do in the next 15 20
this it's kind of hard to add like
attack animations right you know
I mean I could you know what I want to
do is I just want to look through the
data
structures um so I can think about if
there's a better way of doing stuff that
might be that might be a useful thing to
do um I'd also like to record a quick
little demo for the
uh for Twitter let's record a quick
little
demo MOA gif
FPS
is uh 10 is fine no 20 I think we do 20
Seconds 50
seconds 500 it'll be
it's not on screen hold on it's not even
on
okay I think that's the full demo let's
see if we get a nice gift out of that
welcome just got a nice demo of
this looks like it
works let's post this and go over some
uh some data structures in the project
so I can figure out some stuff to do
with it tomorrow
oops oh yeah we got lots of cool
environments around here got I have this
one as
well there
I have a hard time solving leak code and
I'm a beginner in coding can you give me
an advice please
uh I am terrible at leak coding because
I've never bothered grinding it because
I've never done that type of job
interview
um solving leak code is absolutely
completely different from the ability to
build stuff leak code is what you do for
job
interviews uh in like General software
engineering um really the only thing you
can do is go study basic data structures
and algorithms and then do a bunch of
those problems because they're not the
type of problem that anybody like nobody
is solving well almost nobody is solving
those problems without having seen them
before like they literally will show up
to the job interview having seen every
possible iteration of all of those
problems
it's a little bit better than this demo
isn't
it let's look at some data structures
for this uh this project before I close
out for
today you give me suggestions about
starting with coding if you want to
actually learn how to build stuff
and not hate it um I suggest that you
pick very very simple basic projects um
like with your ability okay if you're
asking me what language I'm going to
assume very simple
um you know if you're just getting into
stuff python is a nice starting point
um it doesn't teach you a lot of the
fundamental things that you will need
later on um even if you are working in
py on but it's it's a nice easy starting
point and it will let you build very
basic projects very soon
um there like I guess some cool stuff I
remember like one of the really basic
projects I would do is you could
Implement image filters image filters
will teach you like basic loops and
basic uh data manipulation and they're
kind of cool cuz you can make like uh
you know an edge filter in like 10 lines
of code or you can Implement stuff like
that
yeah python has a lot of learning
resources and it's the best supported
things by llms so you can probably ask
them for like advice kind of like a
personalized tutor as long as stuff
doesn't get too complicated um I think
that that's probably a really good use
case for
it but yeah the content here
is the content here is um
research I mean I started when I started
programming I started programming by
like making Minecraft mods had no idea
what I was doing but it was fun so like
I did a lot of it right and then after
that I started making my own little
projects I don't know I made like a
couple little cool combat
simulators um I did a couple like really
basic AI things and then once I sort of
got the ropes of that I started doing a
basic AI research and then I got better
at it and I started you know actually
doing cool stuff from
there I mean I can give you a couple
things the thing I'm using right now I
really like um rib for graphics if you
want to do anything with Graphics really
really simple and easy
Library very
nice which coding Industries will solve
AI I mean shortterm or longterm right
um like long-term nothing if you think
AI is going to solve everything but I
fail to see how there's a world in which
programming is not valuable and there
are other things that are valuable like
I think that programming is going to be
like one of the last things to actually
be fully
replaced like by the time programming is
automated like programming solves
everything so that just means everything
is
solved I started brain dead copying
tensorflow 1.0 tutorials not knowing
what the was happening oh man I
started you had it easy in tensorflow
1.0 let me tell you back in my day we
had Cafe 1.0 where you wrote These God
awul schema files or whatever like these
config files and it like came up with
the neural net for you and you couldn't
edit it or do anything with
it wait let me let me find let me find a
fun sci-fi picture
yeah okay so by the time AI solves all
of coding I think that uh civilization
looks like this so I think you're good
web development is probably going to be
the first one getting
replaced I also tried to write a neural
network in Java it was not a fun
time
uh well if you want the really the
really amusing take is like you don't
need AI replace the majority of
programmers right like the like the
majority of programmers can be replaced
by simply not having them because
they're doing negative work
um yeah like you need to be when you're
like working on a larger project or even
a medium-sized project like you need to
know what you're doing to actually be
adding value to it um so that's the real
like you know what when will AI replace
things um yeah
web dev is a nightmare I actually I've
done zero web dev in my time because I
just I have a very low tolerance for
really terrible uh programming Stacks I
probably should do some so I can put all
these cool environments on online
somehow
but I I can't deal with the stack the
web stack gets worse every year it's
ridiculous somehow it gets worse every
year I was going to look at data
structures
here hey it's cool that I see four on
Twitch so I guess there is some
discoverability there that's kind of
cool
I haven't even advertised anything with
the twitch that's kind of
nice
um so the thing what do you consider
webd I picked your building WordPress
websites for people with minimal
interaction with
plugins to be webbed
of oh I don't know it's
you never make an the thing is you never
make an engine to like
do the thing that you want like the
engine for building your custom website
is called code right that's that's the
engine for building your website Ian you
can paper over it with like a whole
bunch of things to write specific
code but it's really hard to replace
just writing general purpose code
it's like it's like asking like when
will you know here it's like asking when
will uh AI replace math or English or
something
right or when will scratch replace you
know meain actual languages it's yeah
and I wish it would replace everything
because then you know if it replaced
everything then I wouldn't have to do
all this I wouldn't have to work on all
these things everything would be solved
and that would be great
I see a lot of people on uh on Twitter
working with these like these crazy AI
workflows where they're basically just
like telling the AI fix the bugs yeah
there are more bugs fix those yep keep
fixing those and like they keep just
hitting enter until it eventually kind
of works and they have like some giant
garbage heap of code written by whatever
llm and it that just does not sound like
a fun
time yeah it's
nuts I mean there's this demo
online yeah like right how could you
possibly maintain that I mean I say that
having written this complete garbage
script today but like I'm not it's not
going to stay this way it's getting
refactored and it's going to get
refactored way better than llm could
refactor it right
the thing that's happened in AI that's
really obnoxious know was having been in
this space for years like you saw all
the shields in web2 right all like the
Shields and scammers in web2 and then
they moved over to crypto and nfts and
like web 3 and like all these various
different things oh yeah it was iot at
one point right and now they've all
moved into AI so like there are serious
people in AI that are like having fun
spec ulating about where it might go
right but then there are also a bunch of
shs that are like oh it's going to like
everything is going to be solved next
year there'll be no programmers in two
years like don't listen to those
people they're
nuts and again I would very much like it
if AI did solve everything I'd have a
lot less work to have to do right
I could come back from my run in the
morning and go take a 4our nap instead
of sitting here and writing code for
four hours that would be
nice I'm trying to think if there's a
way to design this
thing without needing
pids if you think about it the PID
system is really just pointers to all
the entities in this
game like I've reinvented pointers but
in a way that makes sense with
numpy underlying technology might be
there in a matter of years mountain of
processing place that involve people
that won't
be the other thing is just like
programming skill a programming skill is
exponential like one really good Dev can
do exponentially more than you know a
bunch of bunch of mediocre
devs
right I know don't get too caught up in
the whole
like you can just like you can scroll
Twitter all day and like follow a bunch
of shills and have a bad time or you can
like close Twitter and actually build
stuff
right what are you thinking with your
player pointers yeah so it's really
obnoxious here because I know how to
build this in Python
right in Python I know how to build this
crazy inefficiently right you just have
your grid and you have this 2D grid
right and it's just a list of lists and
then each element in this 2D grid will
just be your uh object which is like
your player or your Tower or whatever
and you just check if like it's empty
the specific spot on the list is empty
in the grid and that will tell you um
whether you know you can move there or
not and then you don't have to worry
about uh screwing up you know with this
these pids and like getting them wrong
and you know having them be out of sync
and stuff because they're directly
references to the objects what I've done
is i' I've kind of reinvented pointers
with this PID system because I don't
think you can make you can't make like
an me map of pointers directly and even
if you did then you'd have to deal with
like d reference checks and stuff so
that's essentially what python does
right it like does avoid
star it's like a 2d array of void star
that handles the D referencing for you
um but I'm not sure if there's a better
way to do it than I'm doing
now that's the tricky thing because like
right now right I have to assign there's
like a range of pids that is the Players
there's a range of pids that correspond
to Towers there's going to be like a
range of pids that corresponds to creeps
and like unless I'm going to do weird
Union type things which I don't even
know how to do in C I can't write a
function that's like get object from PID
because that function needs to know
whether it returns a player a a tower or
a creep or whatever else I decid to put
in the game right so like I can't return
a generic a generic thing um I don't
think you can sub I don't think there's
like any struct inheritance things pids
are essentially coordinates they are
indices uh the pids tell you which it's
player ID so pit is it tells you like I
have a list of um or not a list I have
like in a big array of players so if I
have like pit zero I go look into the
first row or whatever and that's where
the players are it's like a pointer um
but I need it to work for I have
multiple different object types or
multiple different struct types because
like I have this player struct here I've
got this creep struct I've got this
Tower struct and unless I can like
unless there's a union type in this that
I can use which is still kind of garbage
um there's not really a way to just
easily keep track of what is where on
that grid and I mean at the same time
I've got I have like this actual thing
that's the environment grid that tells
you what type of thing is
there so like the the grid tells you if
it's like a player a tower a creep but
it doesn't tell you which one it is and
then I have this PID map that tells you
which one it is right but doesn't
directly without looking it up tell you
the material type or whatever so there's
just all this stuff going on and like
it's introducing these additional layers
of indirection that are the main source
of bugs at the moment so I'm trying to
think if there's a way I can re-engineer
this thing somehow to be simpler on that
front I really like what I was able to
do with
um uh player OBS here and creeps and
Towers like these are really simple cuz
these are just m Maps over players
creeps and Towers right there's no
pointer Shenanigans here there no Segal
potential it's very nice
um but this PID thing this pit and this
grid these are not nice
yeah I don't want to drink the O
Kool-Aid it's a mess I mean the thing
is okay so
technically technically I could decide
that I'm going to just have one struck
type right cuz they're pretty similar
and then I could just end up with having
like some of these that have um know
there could just be an INT entity type
for instance so I have one struct and
then there's like an entity type that is
a part of the struct that tells you if
it's a player a creep a tower and stuff
like that so I could do
that and
then and then
what I still wouldn't be able to make
like a 2d grid of these things
um I don't know how this would
work so wait if I
made so
complicated no this is a me
map what are you going to do with the IL
Els checks all over the place to deal
with different entity types well I have
those right now
right it's driving me nuts
so the whole reason that this stuff
exists right is to do um local like
local Collision checks and stuff like
the reason that there's a
grid is so that uh when you move a
player right you discretize the
positions and you can see if there's
something in what would be the
discretized grid cell that you're moving
into too so that's how I get Collision
checks for free and how they're
incredibly efficient because it's just
is there something in the block that
you're in yes or no incredibly
incredibly efficient
um
similarly similarly right like when you
make when you make an attack against
something
well let's say for computing the
observations right like when you need to
see what agents are nearby you in order
to select one to attack or do something
like that um you need to know which
agents are around you on a grid it needs
to be a grid because otherwise you have
to do the O of and squared check over
all the entities in the scene and that
scales absolutely terribly so unless I'm
going to commit to there being like you
know 100 total things and even that's
probably too slow
um it's just not a good way of handling
it
right though I really don't like having
to have a grid and entities it's really
obnoxious because like when you have a
grid uh grid scale very poorly with the
size of the observation window right so
like if you want to have a grid for what
would be a full-size game window in an
actual like AAA game that you're playing
um that doesn't work because you have to
partition the screen up into small
enough grid cells and that ends up being
way too much data to put into your
neural network so entity based stuff is
incredibly incredibly efficient for that
because like there are five players on
your screen right they go into an
array you can limit the amount of
neighbor St
by using something like quad yes so you
can technically you can go from N2 to uh
n log n or whatever it is with quad
trees
right but it's nlog again with a
potentially big constant on it because
you have to get a really efficient quad
Tre
implementation right now it's 0 of
one right now the uh the neighbor check
is O of
one you you do something like spatial
hashing which is also I think o of one
but
um if you do that then it it's 0 of one
with a gigantic constant is the
thing willing to eat the cost of larger
data if it means
faster data
access well I'm willing there I'm
willing for there to be larger data on
the simulator right the simulator has
lots of memory I don't care about that
uh I am not willing to eat the cost of
larger data going into the neural
network that's really
bad now I mean that said
like it's really hard to think how you
would get
around um having at least some sort of
nav mesh right you probably need some
sort of nav mesh
anyways cuz like you at least need to
know like passible or not passible for
the
map data going into the neural network
means the grid well if think about it
right so like let's look at
this it can be whatever you want it to
be like the way to think about this is
oops when I'm playing this game right I
see the screen I see pixels that's a
huge amount of data and not to mention
it's really slow to render all this so
you can represent this to the neural
network however you want um one obvious
way is like each of these tiles here
right you can see like the the part the
partitioning of this right it's really
Jagged so you can give it a map in which
you have whoops not sure what happened
there oh it's just it's trying to render
so you can give it um you can give it
let's say like a binary map that just
tells you which um like which tiles are
available you can do something like that
if I really wanted to go nuts with this
I could even pack it so that each like I
could pack it with just a binary map for
the nav mesh uh I could pack it into
like eight tiles per bite or something
if I wanted to I don't know how bad
memory bandwidth is I think it's it's
pretty pretty significant cuz it all has
to go on the GPU which is pretty slow so
I could technically pack like 32 tiles
per uh per integer if I wanted to do it
that way though that's kind of
complicated um it would be really nice
if I didn't have to do a nav mesh at all
but I don't know how you represent the
terrain without having a nav mesh now if
you ignore that everything except the
terrain doesn't have to be represented
that way right like look even here I can
only see like 10 things on screen right
now so I can just give you you know my
position their positions our healths
stuff like that and if that's like I
don't know U maybe five or 10 integers
or floats per agent that's only like
what 200 bytes that's reasonable you can
do
that but this dual representation is
just really obnoxious
because it makes the neural network very
complicated and it makes writing the
code very complicated
used to managing complexity through
abstraction well like there's nothing to
abstract here it's just like how do you
present your data
right I mean so this here this is like
this is a quite substantial panel to add
in this is like what is this 40 by 20 or
something
um so that's already that's like 800
bits minimum with optimal compression
800 bits of
data um so 200 bytes not terrible but
then you have to do the compression
inside the neural network so it's
unclear whether you'd want to compress
it in the first place so that could be
as much
as uh 800 bytes of
data uh this could be as much as 800
bytes of data which is like already a
kind of substantial addition to your
observations you could do it I guess um
but then you have this giant map that
has to go into probably a convet which
is going to going to be slow that
already just like that probably limits
you to not being able to hit a million
steps per
second I mean I could try to do
something with
like I could try to give you like a very
local nav mesh or something or I could
like just give you if you're about to
hit a
wall but that doesn't seem like doesn't
seem like a great
option I could give you a coarser
version of this thing right like I could
uh I could like chunk this up so that
each four blocks is one block maybe that
would give you like a really coarse nav
mesh that might
work and then we use entity based
observations for the rest of stuff but
it still doesn't make it any easier to
do the representation
right so here technically right
technically I could make a player M map
which is a 2d array of
player and I could have one type for
everything but then I'm pretty sure
because this is a m map I'm pretty sure
that the actual data structure is not
it's not a 2d array of pointers it's a
2d array of the actual data so whenever
I move a player onto that I have to copy
the whole player which is
slow I don't want to have to do that
because moving pids around is actually
really really computationally efficient
even though it's
obnoxious the only R the only reason
that you would want to copy players
around like I just mentioned is if
you're going to compute observations by
just slicing directly into the player
map
which I guess you can
do but it's a lot of
hard haven't even gotten to the
obnoxious neural networks that are
required to handle entity based data
though they can be made very
efficient it's seven so I'm going to
think about this for a couple more
minutes and then I'm going to go to
dinner if anybody has any like random
generic RL questions I wouldn't mind
answering a few of those but I'm
probably just going to have to sleep on
this out of my wheelhouse I'm in watch
mode
yeah understandable I mean this is these
are variations of the problems that have
just been always been difficult in the
field for years um it all comes down
to representing your game state or your
simulator state in a way that is both
good for the simulator being fast and
good for the reinforcement learning and
that's very very hard to do well
well and the developer as well yes so
it's not absolutely got awful to write
um
I mean I could probably prettify the PID
thing so it's not too bad right um but
yeah anytime you're doing anything with
an object right like anytime you have
something that just like function needs
to be applied over an object in the
space you're going to need to have paths
for every single type of
object it's like an entity
unless of course right I make it just
one struct that's just
entities I could just do entities like
that yeah code paths multiple code paths
like you're going to have to do some
conditional on the player ID and like if
the player ID is less than the number of
players then it's a player otherwise if
it's less than the players plus creeps
it's going to be creep otherwise it's a
tower um It's actually kind of cleaner
to just have one struct type that is
entity kind of just cleaner to have one
struct type that is
entity and then because a lot of the
time when you're getting an entity you
don't care right you don't care about
what it is you just care like you want
the position or something so I think
that codewise if you can just get the
entity and then you can get like entity
y entity X or whatever and then if you
need to know you can do like entity do
you know type or whatever and you can
get as player or creep or
Tower right as an enum something like
that that's
good can python structs have behavior on
them or just dat data uh these are not
python strs these are native C strs this
is uh scon syntactic sugar over c
structs
um I guess technically they could
probably have a function on them I think
it would be a void
star but it's like if you could do it
the exact you'd do it the exact way as C
so you'd be Reinventing stuff
yeah yeah python doesn't have a struct
keyword it's one of the things I really
really wish the language had was a
proper struct keyword it drives me
nuts but hey it's in
scon yeah these are literally these are
one to one with
cs can you clean up The Code pth by
putting some of the branching behavior
on the struct
itself you are trying to do Dynamic
dispatch I think um you're trying to
like have you're trying to do the
pattern
where you know you're so you're right
but that's like not something in this
language um so you're trying to do
Dynamic dispatch where you have multiple
implementations and then you can like
get entity right and then call entity
like entity. attack or whatever or
entity like. take damage or something
and have different implementations for
each of these um that does not really
exist
or if you did exist you'd have to
exist or if you did exist you'd have to implement it with like void Stars
I kind of do like flipping it it's it's
kind of gross in some ways to
have
um I guess in theory if there's a single
entity you could at least hide some of
the branching logic in the entity
instead of your simulation code well
it's not so much that you can hide the
branching logic in the entity because
the entity is still not going to have
methods um it's that like you don't
always need to know what type of entity
it is right like a lot of the time you
just need to know the position of a
thing
right especially like if all the
entities have health and stuff
that makes it really easy to do stuff
because like all the functions can take
either an ID a PID or they can just take
like an entity star or an
entity entity
reference but the place where it's gross
is like um you end up with like a lot of
like Towers in that case like Tower is
going to have like skill tags and stuff
from players and they're just going to
be
unused this is what people use like
Union types
for though I don't really think the
union type
solve that problem so
much problem gets worse as you introduce
more entity types yeah it does I mean
the thing is this is not like an
infinite scoped project right this is
supposed to be a relatively small scoped
mini MOBA so like they're going the
entities that they're going to be
they're going to be Towers they're going
to be creeps there might be a few
different types of creeps right which
could just be you know creeps that have
different attacks or whatever um maybe
there'll be a few types who knows
they're going to be
players what else is there in am MOA I
don't know maybe they'll be like a
bounty Rune or like a neutral or
something like
that but maybe those will just be
implemented as different sted creeps I
don't know depends if I want to have
like a unique identifier so I can render
them
differently but even then it's not that
bad
because your logic kind of goes course
to fine right because like first you
know it's an entity The Entity has some
properties right and then like you could
check you can check like you know uh
type and you can see that it's like a
player a creep or a tower
maybe and then like maybe there's like a
creep type attribute or whatever that
only creeps use and if you really need
to know what type of creep it is which
you don't need to know for most things
right like maybe if you kill it and you
get a different amount of XP or
something you need to know but most of
the time you don't need to know so if
you really need to know that you can
check it and Branch the logic based on
that
um but when you at least if you like
Union all the
strs together if you have like a union
all the trucks is not that bad
also means that when you add uh add no
more types you don't have to add like
different stuff into the function
signatures it's not
bad it's pretty darn efficient you don't
have to check against multiple types you
don't have to do branching Logic on PID
but you don't have to do branching Logic
on pit at all in
fact uh
they they might not even need to have a
PID right in the struct I don't think
that they need to even have a pit in the
struct necessarily at that point because
you know you know it has the type so you
don't need to branch on
PID so that could be better
looking at this thing right now
basically they're all the same
anyways gain the benefits of
polymorphism it's not really
polymorphism it's very explicit and
procedural um the one gross thing is
like having everything in the trucks but
the thing is for reinforcement learning
right
like because this is for reinforcement
learning I kind of don't want to give
you like a sub dictionary that has
uh agents in a subdictionary with Creeps
in a subdictionary like I don't want to
give you a bunch of different
subdictionaries I probably just want to
give you one big block of entities
anyways because that will be more
efficient to process with a neural
network does that make sense like if I
just give you all the entities in one
big block you run your neuronet forward
path parallelized over that whole big
block whereas if I give you like three
slightly different strs one for creeps
one for players one for Towers or
whatever then you need to have like
different modules in your neuronet to
process all that stuff yeah neuron Nets
prefer flat data
always and this is very compact data as
well because the way that this would
work so let's say you have this
representation where your game
internally has this giant block of
entities right then the way that it's
going to work in your neuronet is when
you compute observations you're just
going to pick like the 10 nearest ones
or like you're going to arbitrarily Pick
10 entities from the grid and you're
going to put them into those
observations and then you're just going
to observe those 10 right so you're
going to have a very small partiel of
data you still have to keep the grid
representation in order to quickly
compute which agents are nearby and
stuff but a lot of the logic does get
simple
there's a really good post on this by
the way by a friend of mine if you want
to look at it
um you look up like entity gy clemens's
blog he's got this really amazing post
he wrote this crazy cracked engine in
Rust for uh doing this type of
stuff not all of it is needed in
particular I don't think that the Ragged
buffers I think that they add more
complexity than they're worth most of
the time um but yeah this is the type of
stuff do you end up with Edge case
problems where a tower has a bunch of
stuff around
it and most of them are
friendlies which should be ignoring them
anyways
um since you don't have sub dictionaries
to filter
that you would end up with that problem
anyways because the way that you're
checking nearby stuff is by iterating
over um nearby
tiles now the thing is okay the other
question right is like is that even
tenable because if you're iterating over
nearby tiles you fundamentally like you
can't make the view range of stuff very
long so maybe you were right originally
with your quad trees thing right
your sub dictionary doesn't filter by
friendly well the thing is if you need
to know you just do like team right like
there'll just be like a do team
attribute that you can like that you can
check uh and it's you're not filtering
you're looping anyways and the loops are
fast because it's cython their c-s
speed the question is just like the the
question is really just one of
representation um grid based views scale
absolutely terribly over large
spaces um and uh pure entity based
comparison scale absolutely terribly
with number of entities so grid based
views are quadratic with size of window
and entity based filters are quadratic
with number of entities with both of
these potentially having options to uh
make it n log n with quad Tre like
um I don't know why I've got Politics on
my freaking feed it's supposed to be
stuff this is actually this is so crazy
this has been running now for almost
here
wow okay I I'm going to take I I got to
go in a second but because I need dinner
but I just want to show you how insane
this is so these runs
here this is running now 150 experiments
of minimum 500 million steps each which
is like I've seen experiments by
researchers that go to like 10 million
very often right depending if you have
slow environment so this is 150x between
500 mil and over a billion steps so this
is like at least 75 million step 75
billion steps worth of
data and this hyperparameter tuning
algorithm is still discovering better
and better
Solutions my manual one like from my
previous hyperparameter tuning run the
best thing that I found was like right
here
I don't even know if I found something
this
good this is insane I'm glad I left this
thing running carbs is an awesome
awesome algorithm holy hell
looks like it's upping the update Epoch
which is a little bit
funny that's insane though how that
we filter out the bad runs and look at
that
well I think tomorrow I'll try out I'll
at the very least I'll try out uh
switching this to be one entity type
unless I think of a dumb unless I figure
out that that's a dumb idea um since it
produces data and then I will just think
about data structures a little bit for
grids
versus uh
entities
and yeah I'm just going to have to think
about how that
works I mean for this type of
environment they're going to
uh like 13 or 14 by
14 observation range it's not very
far all right
well I'm stumped up for now um
so I'm going to sign off I'll be back
tomorrow probably a little later than I
started today I go for a slightly longer
run on Wednesdays and uh we'll be still
working on this I've also I've got a few
side things that I've need to finish up
as well I might do that before I hop on
we'll see thanks for stopping by and uh
yeah lots of cool progress on this
project this is looking very very nice
for just two days of work um and I think
in like a full week's worth of stuff
this is going to going actually start
looking like a proper mini
MOBA uh the runs are brutal this is a 53
mile week um while power lifting five
days a week as well so anyways night